What is that song? It must have been a part B O. Is it a part B O? That movie? Is it Isate? Isate? Isate? Whatever.
Isate. That's absolutely. I'm sorry Vod. My Vodry flings. My Voi flings? Vodlings. Oh Vodlings just
right you probably shouldn't hear anything about that audio.
Oh I hear myself. Good morning, good evening, good afternoon. I'm so sorry I'm late. Oh my god,
nine minutes late. Mummy fucking despise of us. What in the fuck? I'm not. I don't. I love you.
I'm sorry for being late. I have a bit of an update about the V-Lore game.
Hello? Yeah. I have a bit of an update about the V-Lore game. I got sent the beta? No, it's not a beta.
I got sent the part where it's before it gets shipped and we want to put notes in.
That's what I got sent. I played it. It's got progression. All I'm going to say is goddamn.
It's got progression. So there is a gameplay mechanic and it worked. It pulled itself off.
I obviously cannot say too much. But yes, the V-Lore video game, the estimated date to,
the estimated date, the producer, Samadess, I don't know what you want to call him. Oh my god,
it's the male that's producing the video game, male mansion. Yes, I'm sorry you had to find out
this one. It's a guy who produced the game. I'm sorry I had to beat you. He said that the
ninth? He said it's possible for a launch on the sixth. I'm going to send over my thoughts on my
notes. I'm going to see how long it takes to implement what my thoughts are. I'm going to send it to
a few other team members. I've got four. No, I've got three other team members I'm going to send it
to. The fourth one, not right now, that are going to play it as well. They're going to have access
to it and they're going to tell me what their thoughts are. Male on game. No, you're the male
end game. You're the one doing that with all my daughters. So you're welcome. You're welcome
that I paid for you to cuck me with my own daughters. You're welcome. And I hope you do come well.
Did you do your own route first? No. I'm just my fellow Americans. I'm going to just say this,
my route isn't perfect, but everyone else's came out the way. It was
Nintendo. Okay, Nintendo. Got it. Intended. But this ain't a game for kids.
More like Yahoo. The daughter and mummy and the mummy. You mean domain expansion, malevolent
bank show. It's so, so good. I will be doing it over and over again. Yes, unfortunately,
it didn't come out the way. However, if there was to be a video game in the future.
What's that? Oh, you heard it. Wait, do you go back to the start of the
VOD to get the Vodlings treat? How did you do that? Crazy Jesse, thank you for the tip.
And okay, no, you have to discover the lore for yourself if you don't know what the Vodlings get
just to discover yourself. How long does the game take for one route? It is linear,
but you can make different choices along that linear path, but your start and end will always
be the same. Does that make sense? Does that make sense? So the start and end will always be, well,
granted you fucking win, the start and end will be the same. If you lose, you have to click retry
because you suck. And if you want the good suck, you're going to have to unsuck to get sucked.
Okay, so yeah. So it doesn't matter what we do. So you can get extra voice lines,
but basically my recommendation going into playing the game is pick your Oshi first.
That pick your order of preference first because you will be rewarded instantly. Or if you're a
bit of a long gratification person, pick your not least favorite. That's not, maybe that's not
the phrasing we want to say around these parts for Veiler. Your least watched girl. Pick her first
and then build up to your Oshi desu Veiler and then you might be able to enjoy it. So yeah,
suck, unsuck to get sucked. All right, I'm picking it. Pick your order. No, I'm not doing the vocal
for him. So again, sorry I took so long. I'm gonna keep it above 50. I don't feel very good right
now. I feel very sick, but that's just because, you know,
we're playing a knockoff game called TCG Card Jump Simulator Prologue.
How is your voice after all though? It's very sore to do. The microphone completely
heights how messed up my voice is. It really does. So we're playing a game called,
we're playing a game called Card Shop Simulator Prologue. Okay, but this isn't the full game.
It comes out in November. Who goes there? Also, I absolutely love the latest ASMR video. Oh did you?
Oh no, the next one's not talking. The next one is just not talking. Wait, should I check out the
comments on YouTube? Hold on, I can check out the comments on YouTube. Oh no. Yeah, I feel like when
I do unscripted rambling ASMR, I kind of, I kind of, oh people are timestamping when they came in
the game on Overwatch. That's okay. I had so much fun in that Overwatch. Yes, right, the next one's
not talking, but I hope that, what's the word? Oh no, what's the word? What do I hope?
Well, I've lost it anyway. Anyone else got a train of thought? Oh, I got it. I came back.
I've got about five more-ish recorded ASMRs that I can put on YouTube for the milestones,
and then, I'm gonna,
This is a refling from the future. Stronny turns into an Overwatch streamer from here on out.
No, it don't. With weekly Overwatch endurance streams. We're reaching GM with Mama.
I suck at Overwatch. Are you true?
Oh, you think- Oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh. Hold on, I'm gonna go back to all these.
The game is available on a website that I personally like to dub. It's free to play.
Free to play one-handed.
But it is free to play unironically. I ate the cost, you're welcome.
I ate the cost, I also fucked it up so that's why no one could be mad when they play it and
they'll be like, oh this game is shit, fuck you. I ate the cost. Right, Future Reefblade.
No, I'm not going to be an Overwatch streamer. Yes, I'll play Overwatch with you again at
a later date, however, because I actually really enjoyed that. I got really lightheaded though.
But yes, right, Future Reefblade. No, I'm not Grandmaster, I suck at the game.
Grimmed by Vealor, I can't believe I have to say that out loud, thank you.
Why do I feel like Vealor, some of Vealor, we're harder to rid than others.
You think I put my money into a boring, a boring resident sleeper VN click thing?
No, there's gameplay. Okay, my fellow Americans. There's gameplay, that's why it cost a pretty
penny because there's gameplay. So boring, snoozefest, resident sleeper. No, we play video games in
this house. You have to air in those cutscenes. Okay, I like VNs though. Oh.
You want a wholesome VN from us? I might be able to do that
because I have a contact for a wholesome Vealor VN if you want it. I can make it happen.
The game will be harder than Elzin Ring. No, there's a few balancing issues, but
I can't believe I'm, yes, there's balancing needed in the game. I'm not kidding.
But it's one of those games where you get a quite, quite fast gratification for progressing
because it's like, unlock, you unlock this, you unlock that, you unlock this.
And then things get, because then it gets easy. That's what I like in my video games. I like when
it's hard at the start and then you start unlocking stuff and then you start being able to
and because it's a shorter game, you're going to get that hit of serotonin all through it.
I mean, you're probably going to get hit of serotonin every cutscene as well if you've got a
few in the tank. Thank you. Thank you. Yes, M&S 188. Do you know if the game will be available?
Yes, it's you. It's not going on Steam, however, it's not going on Steam.
Anonymous? Oh, unless Brian and Dr.
Never said it would be boring. I just think someone would be more of a challenge than others.
I'm teasing. But I like a challenge actually.
A challenge? I'd say if you want a challenge, pick your Oshi first because it's just you and her.
What could I be hinting to? I feel like you guys already know.
I feel like you already know what the base game's about or what it was based on. I don't think it's
a thing. Anonymous, my mummy's money and blessings, I will gladly sacrifice to my record and plop every
girl equally in the game. Yes, you. So before anyone's like, I am exclusive to one girl at VLR,
well, you're going to be shutting the game down after one segment, if you will, because
yeah, pick your Oshi and then you get one segment. Congrats, like fucking. It's not like the others
didn't put effort into Jesus Christ. But obviously because it was the first time I've ever kind of
put a game together of that scale, I fucked up. I've told the girls I fucked up and I said to them,
look, there might be more options down the lane. Like if you guys want a wholesome VN,
that's actually rather plausible. That will be available on Steam. Now, unfortunately,
that would have to cost money. I wouldn't make it cost much because I'd make a deal with the
developer because I have a developer that I know for that. Just wait till mumma trolls the
reeflings. There is no corn, no riz, no gratification, just brain rot. Just wait till mummy trolls the
reeflings. Wait, when would I troll you? In game? I was actually... Oh no, I can't say that yet
because it's a treat for years. Oh, there's a treat coming up and I was going to ask my
treaty McBeaty if they wanted to...
Oh right, okay, no, that's a treat that comes later.
I think I got six hours again, which was really good. I didn't get my post-stream nap. I couldn't
nap. I was raging. I was like, excuse me, I genuinely think you guys made me so excited on
Overwatch. I couldn't freaking nap. I got so excited playing games with you, okay? That I
couldn't sleep because normally my nap time's like two hours before I would finish that stream
usually and I think because I blew past that I was like... Too bad for me. I don't have an ocean
wheel or I like all of you for different reasons. Too bad? No, I mean that's good. I mean you play
the whole game and I appreciate everyone's attempts and efforts because everyone tried really hard.
It is a new medium. I said to the girls like, I'm opening to doing another thing as well. That VN
thing. If you actually want to hold some VN, I'll shut you up. I could probably make that happen
a couple of months down the line. Holy fuck, hold on. Hold on. Oh, let me be clear. You need
to give me any time to cook on that one because you can't just smack out a video game skill.
Great. Looking for it. I was asking because my country loves censorship. I'm so sorry you're in
North Korea, refund. Thank you MNS188 for the super chat. I'm fighting and I was like,
can you even joke about that? What, fucking King Jong-un's fucking watching this stream right now?
What the fuck now? The fuck? The book? Uh, debate it, Laura. Thank you for the super chat.
No, you're not trolling me. That King. King Jong-un. Um, dude. Each of the girls appealed to me
at least in some capacity. Oh, that's cute. Wouldn't mind to hold some VN. I actually
would play the fuck out of it. I'm South Korean. I might get targeted.
Thank you.
Strongly in
today run. TCG card shop simulator prologue. That's the best. I ain't got nothing else
in the tank for you. Sorry. I ain't got nothing else. I ain't got nothing else.
Jai jacazae. Thank you for the extended membership. Itchio has a donation option
before download. Would that go to you all? No, it would go to the developer. Um,
if you want to tip because you felt ever so inclined, because I ate, I can't believe I'm,
oh my God, I'm not a good mother. I'm going to say something so real. Because I ate the cost,
if you want to tip, then feel free to tip me. But don't actually feel inclined. Like as I said,
I ate the cost because I worked for it. Please don't worry. I worked my little,
I worked my strong zoo off as I found out my nickname means strong zoo. My nickname means
something, something like that. Right. Anyways, can I have my cup of tea? Right. Once I finish
my cup of tea, we'll play this game. It's a knockoff of supermarket simulator. Apparently,
it's not by the same dev team. Um, it looks so much like it's by the same dev team. They've
just put it under a different freaking name. Okay. I enter chat and then I leave. No,
oh, she's just a mutual fan. But I really like stronti's model here. We heard your chat,
recuperate investment costs. No, no, we're going to have to go through my donuts on stuff all over
again. I need to really start it from the start. This game is pretty neat. I can't wait until it
actually fully comes out. It looks so cute. I want to see if we can collect all the yards.
And so this is basically Pokemon pack cell and simulator. If you know what Pokemon packs are,
um, just the heads up stronti Aussie's harsh on lollipop content. Oh, you'll never guess who's
hosting the game. No, no, we're not hosting the game. I'm not the game. I'm not the publisher.
Well, I'm not publishing it. I'm, I'm, I'm show mommy. Sometimes I can rub my brain cells together
just a little bit. What game? I got here late. The vealer game. Vealer is going to have a game.
Here's my tip. Thank you. Crazy. Jesse for the tip. I mean, you're not wrong.
Stronti, please don't pay for refunds. No, I think I will. No, honestly, because I was like,
oh, you don't have to do it. Right. Let me finish his tea first.
Here's a smart girl. You are. I'm going to train you guys to like my panting. I don't care.
Mommy's always two step forward. Wait, what was that? Nica Caddo avocado thingy? I'm always two
steps ahead of you. Wait, Nica Caddo. You're just here in the background. I'm always two steps ahead
of you. That's so cute. Are you ready? Oh my God, male voices. Two steps ahead. I am always two
steps ahead. Meet me at the Australian government. That's not funny because I could get kicked out
of this country at any minute. That's not funny. I have business to conduct in this country. Please
grant me. Please grant me my visa. I don't think I can watch that. Oh, a little bit too on the news
there. Thanks again for the extended membership. Jackie as well. What happens if you get kicked
out? So if I get kicked out, I might be moving in with a VTuber.
What is that melody? The universe. It sings for my...
And who is that VTuber? I think you already know who I would be moving in with.
Yes. Oh my God, be a VTuber host when? I can't even conduct my own business in there.
I discussed with Syn and obviously in private about the whole situation that's going on with me.
And literally, as I was explaining it, she taped, I'll just come live with me and I'm like, oh,
I mean, that would solve a lot of problems. Could you imagine two fucking streamers in the same
like fucking velar gated community? Oh my God, bro. Oh God, I don't know what the neighbors would
think though. I mean, the way I was screaming yesterday, I'm surprised the polis didn't come
at my door. I was only getting trouble. Be like, sorry guys, the polis are at the door.
He literally gatekeeper and one streamer and one discord kitten sends. Oh my God,
did I groom Syn to let me live with her? Syn and Strony and Codd in the same room. No,
we can even stream that. I'd be over. I'd be over. I'll let me in. Strony versus then Overwatch
too. Well, might be a thing. Yes. Yeah. Soon. How soon?
I'm not allowed to say I don't like it.
Okay. Never beaten the Grumman allegation. Grimmed. Oh my God, Black Ops to split screen
one by one. Oh my God. Well, Reflens be locked in the basement in the streamer house. No, that's
where the imps go. The Reflens are under my bed. Reflens are used as my relief at the end of stream.
I finish streaming, you're all like cowering under the bed and I'm like, Refleng. Oh, Refleng.
I played the Black Ops 6b, I was actually pretty good. Is that real Andrew?
Competitive game sheets are just going to be continuous makeshift. Bro, I watched back when
she joined the Overwatch stream yesterday. We get so hyper around each other. Like,
genuinely so hyper. I was screaming my head off. Like, I was screaming my head off for the... I
was like screaming in general and then as soon as she joined, we started moaning down the mic to
each other like, mmm, baby girls. No, mommy, don't grape us for the 10th hour. Covering is the joke
I was born ready. Oh, are you sitting on top of the pillow already? You know what's coming next?
Between you and Sin, who has the pincers in your relationship? Oh, I don't mean to be mean,
but I think I have the pincers. I love Sin, but I kind of, I kind of dogged on her,
not dogged on her, sorry, that's the wrong terminology. I kind of told a wee thingy about her.
Sin can't look me in the eyes. She really struggles to look me in the eyes.
She just can't do it. She looks everywhere but in my eyes. And I don't know if that's just her
predisposition or she's shy. I don't know if she struggles with it in general or it's just me,
but we always have the best conversations, like looking at the floor next to each other.
Ha ha ha ha, who says I'm going to be running away, mama? I'm the refling who is the danger.
Oh, that's good. I am the danger. Thank you, the veiler. That's actually a good one. That's a
freaking bad. So Sin is a bomb. Of course she gets hit. Sin knew that she couldn't look me in the
eyes because, ah, you haven't seen me in how many years she kept, well, put it this way. I'm going
to be surprised if all of a sudden you start looking me in the eyes. Look, that's all I'm saying.
I was saying to the reflins if my visa gets denied, I'm living way up. I'm literally your problem now.
I'm literally your child, baby. Ya cow? Ah, ya cow. Hold on. Let me finish this.
You leave my true autism alone. I know, but it's cute and endearing Sin. They love it. It's
because no one else can tell that these kind of cute things about you. Only I can see these cute
things. Sin on stream. I'm trying to think if there's any other quirky things you have that are
adorable. That, you know, obviously isn't. This is why I'm housebound. No, don't say I'm fucking
giving it. I'm don't say I'm turning you into a freaking housebounder. That's terrible. Right,
hopefully I'm not too big, but my watermelon in here going to that place. Oh my god, you heard it
here first. Vila remember gives a indie VTuber agriphobia via internet bullying. Oh my god,
I'm cancelled. Oh, I'm cancelled. Oh my god, you heard it here first. I'm now paranoid that when
I talk to folk, I'm not looking in their eyes. Wait, what are you? Are you not aware? How did
it take you? But I think you must look your family in the eyes, surely. Maybe it's just because I'm
not a family member. Copium. Like, you must look your mum in the eyes. There's no way. There's an
ewe. She also, she also makes sin never. I mean, maybe it's the hate difference. Wait, have you
said to the imps how tall you are? I can't remember if we're told, if you've told the imps how tall
you are and really. Yeah, I'm told as fuck. Okay, okay, yeah. That's where all her confidence is.
As I drown myself in my tea there, did you hear that? Stronny isn't beating the house pet. Oh my
god, that's, I'm fucking writing that down. Oh my god, that's such a good idea. Sorry, I know it's
your idea. Yoink! Hypno house pet. Oh my god, it's in my notes. Thank you, General Therrit,
for the content, the extended membership. Not only did you just pay me, I just paid myself
with your idea. Thank you. Hypno house pet. Oh my god, I'm gonna cream. I have a, oh my god,
I had a hypnosis role play coming up and I didn't know how to do it and you have just given me the
fucking answer. Okay, thank you. I'm leaving now because it's roast o'clock. I'm getting bullied
guys. Oh my god, she's been pissed. VR chat says I'm smaller than Shy Lily. Nice work,
you've been on me. Right, we love you, Sen. Thank you for hanging. Right, no more bullying Sen because
you know, if I do get my visa denied, I do need somewhere to live. So let's put our stonks into
visa. Okay, so we are playing a game called Card Shop TCG Prologue. Now, this is not the
finished version, it is early access, but you are going to know so many simularities between
this game, this game and supermarket simulare. However, they are not by the same game dev.
Now, I believe that for a second. Are you kidding me right now? I believe that.
Cardi Rob, you didn't put a message. Thank you for your tip, but you didn't put a message. Cardi
Rob, you goofy goober. But thank you, that was very kind. Bye Sen, we love you. The scripts just
write themselves. It's like same assets, same layouts, same everything, but it's not by the
same publishers and I'm like, aha. So there's actually, I don't know if you've seen some of it,
there's been a bit of a steam brian. Oh. I can't even deny it. I'm not being funny,
I think Sen would actually be done. If marriage would help whatever thing that we needed, I legit
think that Sen would be done. I ain't being allegations anytime, Sen tiny spiny, thank you.
I think Sen would be done with that. I quit my day job to open my own card store. This is it.
Let's get down to business. Are we invited to the wedding?
I, right, this is going to be called Strony's card input. I'm sure there's,
wait, why can't I do it capital? Oh my god. And then this, no. Okay, I'm out, right. I'll just do
it. We'll do it as an ode to Sen since you started at the start of the stream. Strony's
card input. Wait, is that an extra space? It is. It's done. Okay, task, open phone
tab and stock up on card pack, stock order. All right. Oh, be strong. Okay, be strong.
It's very self-explanatory, so you press, it like literally is the exact same.
It's literally the exact same.
Like, tell me this is, how is this not, the assets are the same, like you can walk around
if you randomly want to walk around and there's, oh, well, you can't go as far, but like, do you
know what I mean? It's this, and it's not the same dev team. And, and I'm like, hmm, curious,
it's not the same, the sound is good. That's the sound you make when, and like the bin is out here
to put your, like, I don't know what to say. Is this not the same game?
Sexy card seller, I am going into battle and I want your cutest cards. Yeah. Seller,
I tell you, I am going into battle and I want only your cutest cards. Oh, that's so cute.
Potion seller, I love potion seller. Oh my God, I need to do that short. That's like,
I keep stalling. I need to do that short. That's like, here's memes, but Scottish
potion seller, I'm going into battle and I need your strongest potions. Like,
I just need to sit down and actually do them. I keep saying, I'm going to do behind the scenes
stuff on ASMR as well, like shorts about it, because Emmy, oh my God, Emmy is like, inspiring me.
She's such a fucking hard worker. And she's so adorable. And I've actually been given
the opportunity. I hope she doesn't mind me talking about this. But I asked Emmy,
like, oh, are you worried to help or anything? And she said she's struggling with writing a script.
And I'm like, please, please let me write the script. Please, please. Please, I love you. Please
let me write the script. So I have the opportunity. I hope it goes well. If I fuck it up, that's on
me though. If I fuck it up, that's on me. Right. I need another shelf already. What is this?
Accessories shop cleanser. Shop level nine. Oh my God, you can sell plushie. Oh my God,
I want to make an e-girl version of this game. Right meow. Right meow. Right. How do I get...
Oh, it's locked. Oh, okay. Right. What do these packs sell for? The market is too...
Well, let's snipe the market. I make 90p, right? That's fine. Interact. And then this is it.
Man the cashier by standing behind the counter and interact. Yeah, sorry. This is the exact same
game. VTuber Shop Simulator. Her ASMR history was fun. Oh, did... You don't... That was an ASMR.
Are you talking to me right now? Didn't she not, you know...
No! Thank you, Groomed by Vila. It's not here yet. The collar's coming first. The dog bowl.
It says it's going to all arrive this month though. Because we're...
Danny turned on the... Sorry, that's rather loud in my head, so...
I'm going to need you to kindly shut the fuck up a little bit.
I think that's fine. What would you like? A card? 24.
Bro, this is the exact same game. This is Supermarket Simulator. How is it from the
different... It has to be the dev... Changes... How much? 18. 10. 15. 16. 17. 18.
One, two, three, four.
Take it. Hold. To give. Give. Done. Okay, it was the space bar. Sorry, jeez.
This is literally the exact same game. It's the same game, but with cards.
I'm sure there were still tingles happening. No, I don't know. I get like really
...preniquity when I'm like not feeling well. You know what I'm saying? Like, wait, wait, that's
right. Definitely looking forward to the Tour of Pricks for the Dog Call. I'm going to,
honestly, I'm going to hold it in my hand and then I'm going to be like, don't you want it?
I need to upload all the artworks I got of us because it was originally going to be an event,
but I don't need to do it for the event anymore because there's a new event.
Stand aside, old event. So, yeah, I'm going to be...
$2.00. You know, dose. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Oh, my God, I'm so good at math.
I literally... Oh, just look at it. I like how everyone enjoys my shop. If I was walking in
the street and it was just a guy at the cashier and all I see is that it's not even flushed to the
wall. Bro, I ain't stuck. I'm not going in there. I'm not getting jumped. Oh, my God,
good luck with your pack. Please enjoy. Change. Giving... Oh, no, sorry. One, two, three, four,
and then 50. Hello. Hello. Good morning. Would you like a receipt with your
orger? Yeah, it looks like the front for some illegal... Literally, how did they mess it up to
it not being flushed with the wall? I'll change it tomorrow because I don't want to stop the
grab packs on the shelf and open them to get cards. Oh, my God. How did I do that?
Get away from me. Did you see that? Hold on. I ain't man the till. I saw his teethies,
but I'm not a dentist. I'm not a dentist. Right, how did it... Hold, take item.
Open pack. Oh, my God. Is this the gacha part?
What does it mean? Seedant, guppy, flammy, esmer... That flammy looks like Cinder's
thing around her tail. Claw. Bro. Are these AI Pokemon?
But we got all new cards. Oh, no. Oh, no, there's customers. There's customers waiting. Oh, we got
Kitsune, Baring, Helio. Oh, that's cute. Like a seeder. Are these like AI Pokemon that got drawn?
These are actually like genuinely look like they could be Pokemon's. Am I good mental?
They don't look drawn AI, but the designs are like really good. These look like Pokemon. Am I
going mental? They're so cute. Nocti, Sun, Floor, Shiloh, Hanya, Klopp. Bro, these are so cute.
It's like Power World. She doesn't know I can't get enough of her and left for Chid and leave.
Oh, my God. It's a fauna mansion. The hippie trooper from Hollow Life fauna, the ASMRist.
It's one of our saplings. Oh, that's so cute. Oh, my God. I'm so sorry to the customers in the
background. I'm too busy. Oh, those are so cute. Come on in. Right. Okay. Are we finished with the
opening? They're customers. Would someone please, like that Helio is not, it's like 3D compared to
the artwork. That's 3D, but then that is drawn, but that looks trace. Are you squidding me right now?
I'd be very curious to see the, that's look, that's look cute or whatever it's called,
Lucario or the blue fighting one. I'll look hard PhD. Thank you for becoming a member.
That is the blue fighting one. Come on from Pokemon. That's the blue fighting one. I like,
that's the orange one. Cloister. Come on. Nimbless. That's the blue swalloop mixed with the
balloon from Gen 5. Come on. No, these are morphed Pokemon. Oh, my God. The customers are being so
patient. Are you squidding me right now? The blue swalloop. I'm going to open everything and only
sell opened cards as a gimmick, naming my shop hot singles in your area. Oh, that's so smart.
A disco man's room with the volume. So it's like a really good business plan.
Okay, they hit each other with the big fat tits from. Oh, sorry. Oh, no, she doesn't like when
you mention them anymore. Sorry. Sorry. Desole, that was my bad. I got the memo. I was there for the
memo. See, Dan? Nanome. Oh, they're so cute. How am I getting you? I've seen you before.
Like that's Neubat. That's literally Neubat reskin. I'd be very curious to see what the behind
the scene dev notes are on this one. But I'm a sucker. I'm getting, I have to admit, when I hear
the little biding, when I hear the little biding, yeah, when I hear that, I'm getting a wee bit.
I'm getting a wee, a few dopamine hits inside my, that's Tor, that's what, not Torchik. The other
one. The thing in the egg. Togopee. That's Togopee. Come on. I don't know who that's supposed to be.
That's the, it's like Dan Manu thingy, the fire ground type in gen five where you find in the
desert. That's who he is. He's just a reskin. Who are you? The wee purple goblino one?
Oh God. I cannot remember Pokemon names. That's just Pikachu's face on a star.
That's just Pikachu's face on a star. Right. Uh, my apologies. Thank you everyone for waiting.
Why did you wait so long? As the owner of the shop just like stands opening packs. You're
rather p- Fucking hell. I know you're, geez, you guys are more addicted to opening these packs than
I am. Oh, I mean, oh my gosh, is it because she's a gamer that she stinks?
Honestly, me when I fire Mon-Max, you do you, darling.
Hi Riplin, thank you for supporting my independent business. How do I do the two? No, zero? What?
No. Two? All right. Sorry. Uh, take me a second there. Oh, I'm going to be such a good shop owner.
Let me open this box. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Average card shop page and a little sniffle of Fermone Maxing.
Oh no, it's getting dark already. My shop's level three. How is it level three? I've never done
anything. They really said, nah, you're getting faster progress in this game. They said it takes
too long in supermarket simulator gift. What have I got? 30, 21 on that one? Okay, I'm going to open
up a new box until, buy a play table and put it in the shop. Tab, DIY, play table. Customers can
play card games here. Good ways to earn extra income. Extra cunts. So many of us. That's terrible.
Uh, right. No, we don't, we want to hide the customers. Like, if you want to enable the
funk sway of a shop, you need to like do it this way. How are we getting so many stinky?
Oh wait, is this the Yu-Gi-Oh! fan? Do you guys remember the Yu-Gi-Oh! tournament thing? They
like, they, you can ban a player for Fermone Maxing. Oh no, she's going to stink out my shop.
I can't believe it. It's a VTuber in the wild. Oh my gosh, you're real. I didn't think you guys were
real. Let 10 customers play in the card shop. Okay, I'll get another table then.
And then I'll buy another shelf. What was that other thing? I don't know.
Uh, right, let's get right into opening this box. Yeah, right. How about,
so the customers can see? Yeah? Yeah, like, look at the dots on the floor as well. This is,
this is just the same. Okay, we need to think about the funk, the funk sway of the shop. Okay,
how about we just put the tables at the back? So if you want a game, there's like a little section
for it. Oh god, the lights, the lights as well. Don't come on. Bro, this is the same dev team. I
don't know who they're fooling. I'm wondering if they got blocked because they have too many early
access games from uploading. I mean, if you have cartoon and green gas coming from you,
surely it's the sign you need to stop. Oh, they're actually playing against each other.
Oh, that's so cool. Oh, I hope you're having fun. I hope you're having fun.
All right, let me restock this other shelf. Or let's just put those things down.
Any convention is going to have smelly people? I wonder if it's just, but
thank you for your business. I wonder if it's just because people didn't get taught like how to
wash themselves and stuff. And like, you need to do it. Like, at least when a pheromone max,
a pheromone max in the comfort of me on home, like I don't need to think out the place.
For anyone else. But is that mummy in the far right corner? Are you saying I'm pheromone
maxing? I'm trying to like mix up the shelves, you know? I feel like if you're picking at random
for booster packs, you know, you want a good... I heard you can play as well. You know what,
you're done. Get put in the bin, crazy Jessie. You're getting put in the bin.
Right, how do I order more stuff? Order. Stop, stop. Oh, something new. We can already...
Bro, the progress in this game is so quick.
They literally are like, uh, yeah, we're not gonna make you wait around to play this game. Do
we go on? If you're gonna go out in public, please for the love of all that is wholly take a damn shower.
Okay, yeah, real, true. I'm gonna sign that one off to head out. Okay, let me put the price on
these. See, like we've already got new item stuff. Right, the market price is 17. 17. 38. I'm like,
hey, what's up? No. Sit your pretty girl. Right, we will stream snipe the market. Wow, so cheap.
Okay, basic car pack. What bargain? Yeah, we don't really like, um, when we do things.
Thank you, the booty lord. We just do take showers, take off a cloth and soap bar,
and a scrubby-dwee-dwee-dwee-dwee all the way down. I'm doing the shower stream next week,
so I'll just talk through myself. I don't know if it's gonna be too loud for the microphone though.
That's not only worry. Do you do TCG in real life? Okay, I have a confession.
Um, and you're not gonna like it. Who is dissatisfied? I'm under, I'm under charging myself.
Um, I have a confession. I want to get into Magic the Gathering, but I don't have time to do it right
now, so when, you know, all is said and done, I might be getting into it. Thank you, Life's
Spiral Reaction for coming a member! Oh, I never checked! Hold on, pause this game. Right, the
game's gonna run in the background, I think. I'm like 99% sure. Did that unlock in your
emoteslot yesterday? Because I was getting, I was getting gifted out the wazoo. I need to check
if I've got another emoteslot. More like emoteslips. Whoa, you can't say that. Oh, right, okay, okay,
it was the Midsma draw one. Okay, right, no, I don't have any emoteslot. Unlock. Hello,
thank you for waiting, even though no one came. Oh, yes, we're open, I'm sorry! Oh my god, I'm
sorry, please come in, I'm sorry. I'm sorry, please come in. I'm gonna slack more, like,
she's only, I'm only, yeah, I'm only doing this for a tit. I'm only running this shop for player
attention. I'm legally retired to try and get you to play Yu-Gi-Oh. There is that Yu-Gi-Oh video
game. Eh, everyone's on Xbox. Bruh, the, the fucking AI did have, it did not care if you
wanted to win. The AI was like, nah, you have to earn it, bitch. I'm like, okay, Jesus. Like,
what role am I playing the fucking victim? Right, so I need to wait. My task is to let
10 customers play. Oh wait, they get animated as well?
You, you have animations while you play? They're thinking, they're thinking. Uh-huh.
They seem to have like a tamed anime. Oh, no, no, it's your turn. Oh shucks, you got me.
Yeah, there's online magic the gathering. Oh, there's a new player as well. Oh, no,
he was just curious, that's all. He just wanted to see how the game was going. You're not the
thinker. We're obligated to keep you away from cards, like, we keep you away from league and wow.
Wait, they gave me money because they played a game? Why would I get money if it's not done?
Wow, so cheap. Wait, what do you mean? Yeah, it's just under market price.
We're not, we're not a billion dollar industry. I don't have to give myself a CEO bonus at the end
of the day. One, two, three, four. Oh my god, I'm so good at getting change. Is my hair covering up the
price on the register? Oops, never thought of that. A MTG waifu tier list would be something.
I read that before Brian did, thank you. KEE? It's got an E at the end of it. Is it KEE or KEE? Oh
my god, no, you must get KEE all the time. It has to be KEE, surely, copy them. Thank you for the
super chat. Thank you for letting me pop your super chat, Cherry. I'm gonna do
Tamiyo for Jen too. Fuck it, I'll look it up. Tamiyo? What's Tamiyo?
Sex! Oh, she's actually really... Wait, what? No, I don't know. I'm not sure about the hair like that.
Why? I think you're the one who's causing dissatisfied customers.
How is it that it's your twin and your twin doesn't have anything to say? What's going on here?
Is no one buying the booster boxes? Are you kidding me right now?
Are you scaring me? I've played MTG for decades. Yeah? The game is currently in Tatters and Hasbro
sucks. I hope you can find some enjoyment out of it. Oh, I'm so sorry. That sucks. It sucks when
stuff like that happens. When like something that you love gets like wrecked out of your
overwatch one. Disco Mansor. I'm so sorry to hear that about Magic Together. I thought it did rather
well. Yeah, I do have animations. They're just hiding them from me. Okay, maybe I should restock
the shelves a bit instead of a rambling away. What's this? Yeah, see, you just need to like...
Oh, I don't have enough money for whatever this is. Sure, a purchase and then... What are you?
Oh, it's just like our big ass box. Oh yeah, we restocking with these bad boys.
Tatters is an exaggeration, but big company bad. Is it just like they keep coming out with stuff that
anyone's really, you know, fussed for? Actually, I do have a Pokemon... Oh, I do have a Pokemon
card opening stream planned. I don't know if that's cringe though. I just like always wanted to get
like a Pokemon card box and open them and see what was inside. Money ruins everything. Look,
when they said that money is the root of all evil, I took that person like...
Oh no, it's the cause of all evil? Or is it the root of all evil? Why aren't these selling? Is anyone
bought in? Oh no, they have kind of bought them. Oh, we get much more profit on the actual box sales
though. Buy a card shelf and put it in the shop. I mean, I'll buy another one. I don't have enough
money. Oh no, he's waiting for someone to play with. I'll sit with you. I'll play with a game with
you. I'm sorry. I don't know how to sit in the chair. Oh, I feel so bad. The refunds just wanted to
play with someone. No, my darling. I promise someone's going to come play with you in a minute. I'm sure
the AI code did someone to come play with you. Money is the root of all evil. Fine, I'll do it
myself. I only got into Magic the Gathering for the Doctor Who collab. What? Right, I'm going to be
honest. The reason why I know about Magic the Gathering, apparently there's really sexy waifu
cards and there's like these pic talks about it and it's like when someone has the Magic the
Gathering deck is like only sexy waifus and stuff and I was like, I mean, not going to lie, that
probably be me with the deck because that's how I pick like my Pokemon as well. Like if the Pokemon
looks nice, I'll pick it. If it's an ugly Pokemon, I didn't win it in my deck. I'm tired of having
cute adorable evolution stage one Pokemon and then by stage three, it's like this big ugly,
bubbly thing. I'm talking about you Mudkip. You are so precious and you're stage one evolution
Mudkip. Who the fuck approved of Swamper? Swamper with the little beady eyes, little pixelated beady
eyes at the end of the fin flap? Who, who did that? Bro, Mudkip is adorable. I love Mudkip.
Exactly. That's why you guys are allowed to ink for free around these parts.
But you got merit though. Thank you the Veil Lord. You got merit though. Agriculture is a
root of all evil. Agriculture is in food supply? Little puny, guardie-vower? Oh my god. I'm getting
sh- god damn we got a baller. Was it payday mister? Geez. Uh and cash? And exact change?
Thank you Reefling. Now go play to your heart's content. Go. No, okay. Just,
you just want to check out the match, how the match was going. Yeah damn he wanted those packs.
Thank you. Right, I am to buy a shelf. Are you squidding me right now? I think, wait no,
what am I to buy? Buy a card shelf. They say greed is the root of all evil, but I think the seed
that started the roots is scarcity itself. Without scarcity how can someone be greedy?
Are you squidding me right now? Artificial scarcity. Oh I'm going to say look up Balan,
wandering night jumpstart 2022. There's anime altar versions of waifu cards too. Are you squidding
me right now? Don't slander the swampert. Right, no. If I, if it was like oh what would you rather
hug? Uh a big ass swampert that's like a fucking, like I don't know with his wee beady eyes or an
adorable little mudkip that goes. If you think mudkip to swampert is bad, don't ever look up
it into incineroar. That's much, much, much, much, much, much worse. Incineroar?
Now hold on a minute, hold on a minute. General Theric, I'm going to say is look up Balan,
wandering night. Balan, wandering night. There's a main altar, wondering night?
A wolf?
It's a wolf? One, one is a girl and one is a wolf. I assume I'm supposed to look at the waifu.
Hey wait, what? The one version's a fucking furry and then one version's a chick.
Oh, thank you for your, uh, your support. Sorry, hold on. I'm, I'm looking up
sexy magic to gathering cards. Please forgive me. Sorry, let me, let me pop them lights on there
to excuse me. M and A, one, eight, eight. Don't slander the swampert. Maybe I will. Maybe I will.
Tiny spiny. If you think thingy, look up Litten, Litten. Okay, let's do it, let's do it. Everybody,
let's get Litten. Is that a joke? I'm going to put it on screen. No, I'm not because it's not a
fucking PNG. Give me a PNG, you bitch. Don't be scared. Uh, my fellow Americans. Don't be scared. Hold
on. I'm gonna just drag it into VTuber Studio. Remember that time that person said don't drag
stuff into VTuber Studio or your dogs yourself? Oh, there's no customers, by the way. I'm not paying
attention. Where's the, I download a file and it never shows up. Come on. VTuber Studio? Hello?
Hello? Is the image too big? Hello? VTuber Studio? Hello? Okay, I guess we'll do it this way.
Maybe the image is too big like your peepee. Why would it be too big?
Oh, there it is. Sorry, that took me a whole second. Okay, maybe too big for VTuber Studio.
Oh my God, it's humongous. Customers, please don't come to the desk. I'm so sorry, I'm not paying
attention. Right, so how do you start with something so kawaii-ny? It's on fours. That's
cute. I like the wee whiskers coming off of it. And then, yeah, I can see it form like it's getting
stronger, it's leveling up. It's got claws now, yeah. And then, where the fuck is that?
No, I do not accept. Sorry, customer, I was on the phone looking at
the fucking Pokemon we hate. Yeah, that's not it. I don't know, literally just turns into a furry.
That's the champ. Is it a good thing? Put cards, put 10 cards on card shelves, set a price for them.
R to open album? Oh no, do I not have any? I must have to have some duplicates.
Am I on? Yeah, okay, I'll sell duplicates. How do I sell it? Close album?
Okay, we'll get rid of some duplicates, because I don't, I actually want to try and collect all
the cards. I don't know how to, I assume we get like more premium, or because we start to get
duplicates really quickly. Okay, uh-huh. I know they only sell for like a penny or whatever, but I'm
not really wanting to go mental on them. I'll just get rid of the duplicates. Either they want them or
they don't. Right, how does the price on them, market price? Oh, I think I'm going to upsell
in the single cards. You know how it is. You know how it is, we're going to upsell in the,
are you squiddin' me right now? If you want to see wild evolution charts, you've got to check out
some Digimon evolution lines, smiley face. Digimon's mental though, they like, it'll start out really
cute. I've seen the meme examples, like something starts off really cute, and then all of a sudden
it just has an AK-47 attached, and everyone's like, um, that escalated quickly. Um, let's see,
0.8, what an upcharge. I'm really, I'm really busting the customers' balls over this price range,
unfortunately. I think they do sell like, single cards like this for more. I don't even touch
smogon anymore. What's smogon? Smogon. I don't, if that's all these nut strokes, I think I didn't
work because I'm foreign. Because of my accent. I would hug both if it is funny. Oh, it is so cute.
Oh, smogon is sweaty compared to pokon. Yeah, literally, I genuinely thought it was like smogon
with all my balls. I was like, oh, okay. Um, get rekt. Vol, vol, tuh, kin, if you, oh, maybe we
should. I saw Shiby did like, the pokemon smasher pass, so I'm familiar, I'm familiar. Now don't
be like, oh my god, you must have infinite knowledge because you said you're familiar, relax.
I've played or I'm aware of generation one to five in pokemon. Pokemon black, I believe,
is generation five. And then that is where my knowledge stops. I tried to play, um, what's that
game? Oh, I'm gonna get more boxes actually. I tried to play the, did I even have enough money?
I have enough money for one. I tried to play the generation that came after. It was like,
was it aloha or something? And I kid you not, the dialogue killed me. I literally was like, I could
not play the game. I think I got to like the first gym and it was still going. It was going and going
and going and going. And I was like, wrap it up and I just gave up. It just would not stop. The
dialogue would not stop. And so, I'm very familiar with pokemon emerald ruby, you know, your version
of it. Three dollars, one, two, three. One, two, one. Thank you for buying the cards though.
You don't have 20 cents on you, sir. You're making me do math. You're making me do math first thing
in the morning. Gen seven, the Hawaii. What was gen six then? How did I mess up so badly?
This is very comfy cozy. I've had a long week, so something cozy helped.
Thanks for being awesome, cozy. I'm glad you like it. No, it's definitely chilly. Unfortunately,
tomorrow's cold alarm is also getting swapped out for something shorter. I don't know what,
but I'll start. I'll feel better the day after tomorrow. I'll be me again.
So, gen six was France. Encontre mes yeux. I summon my pokemon from Zybol.
Yeah, I don't. Gen six was X and Y. Did I play X?
Change. I don't know if I played pokemon. Right, we're gonna have to start putting a sign up.
Look, I don't judge anyone for their habits at home, but in public, if you're making me inhale
your fucking scent, no, you're done. I can't afford to make more accounts for your simulator's
streams. Stop questioning me. So just take my birthday. It's your birthday. I don't know if you
guys saw it. So this is the inspector for roller coaster tycoon. This is also Gary. It was Gary
the inspector. And then this is also Dennis that was spray painting the side of my gas station
simulator. And like the mum as well. And like Elon Musk even in the mix at one point as well.
Coconut bombs all thank you so much and happy birthday. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday.
I don't know if you saw the Twitter interaction. I don't know if you've deleted it or not,
but like I go on Twitter and it's like role playing is me opening up my gas station simulator
and it's like, oh, I'm so happy. It's my first thing you feel. I have seven day alternative
accounts, honestly. Actual official rule in Yugu. You can't stink too bad. Yes. I love that rule.
I remember seeing an online thing. I don't know if it was a magic the gathering meme where it was
like someone's butt crack was out. Oh, painting one. Thank you for the 10 gifted memberships.
Congrats to those who caught it with their face. Thank you. I love how you use the
zero thing is so cute. I don't care. I'm sorry. I demand unity. I just love my door so much.
It's just so nice. Like I don't know if anyone like please don't ever get so
give me that back. How'd that take it back?
I don't fuck it. Just take it. Just take it. It's 5 cent. I think I think the business will
survive. I'm too lazy. Right. 19.2. Thank you again. Pentium one for the extent of membership.
Although please don't ever at the extent no for the 10 gifted memberships and congrats to those
who caught it and please enjoy the emotes. I promise I promise I'm getting actual emotes soon.
All right. They're going to be real emotes soon. Right. I'm just going to do this.
Until the screen goes green. Wow. I got to get me one of these.
Can you guys please buy my duplicates?
Yes. I would like to put it. I literally can't put it down. I can't. Okay. That's cool. Can you
put it down on? I can't. Okay. Something's not. I'm glitching. Oh. Can you go away please?
Okay. Let's. Let's. I don't know why. Yeah. Okay. It just bugged out a little bit.
Okay. I need to try and sell these cards for my next mission. It says sell 10 cards.
Ooh. Feeling lucky today. Are you? Yes. Of course. Anything for you.
See. I love when the reflins support my independent business. Okay.
Yeah. They're so supportive. Real and true. Okay. And you give me the exact change as well.
Damn. That's a lot of reflins coming in. All yours. Yay. Did you get animated? Oh, no.
Right. Okay. Let's put my duplicates. Bonk. All right. And then let's price this one.
I'm really breaking the, breaking the balls. You know me. A little ball breaker I am.
Anyone else want to identify as a ball breaker? We just need to sell five more cards.
Strangely, I want to lick you. What? A plastic chipper shirt. Oh my god. I used to get those
from the corner shop when I was wee. Oh. I don't even know how I'm alive right now
after consuming that. God, this place is. It makes me sick thinking about them.
Sherbert is so good, but I'm going to say the most obvious and dumb thing, but I so sugary.
Like, I don't know how I was like, my tiny little body when I was like, what, five-year-old?
Down in an entire Sherbert line. Bruv. Bruv. I don't know what I was thinking.
May I go membership? Yeah. Maybe. Maybe I hypnotize you into doing it.
A lane. Oh listen, it is in a lane.
Sugar overdose in a single litm. An American equivalent sounds like a go-kart.
Why can't I buy dice? I can sell dice? Hold on a minute. Hold on, I need a new shelf then, don't
know. Oh, this shelf goes both ways. Check out counter? Yeah, available in full version.
All right, so there is more unlockable stuff. So I can hire a refland in this game.
On the other side of the game is the exact same. Like, you're not really feeling anyone.
They want dice. I need, I'm gonna need more shelves. Oh my god, the figures are so cute.
Right, I need more shelves. Let's get, we'll do two. Two more shelves and then we'll do the dice.
Uh, lit. Can I rotate? Rotate with R. E-E-E-E-E. Oh, no, I've done it too far. Can you rotate the other
way? Okay, well, we're just gonna do a little 360. Hold on. Okay, we'll go to that time.
Oh shit, they have code in the window that they don't like.
Uh, I feel like this shop isn't laid out very well, but hey ho.
I'll try, I'll just stick that there. Hi, thank you for waiting.
Well, I'll play a rearrange furniture simulator. No, nothing. Uh, you would like a whole 80 cents.
Oh yeah. Are those the things that is eatable paper? Those are spaceships. Alien spaceships is
what we call them. Um, I, I could put it, hold, hold on. Can I move you a little like over here?
Yeah, that would be gorgeous. That would be stunning. And then I'm going to move a third one
here and then I'll get the double ones like here so it's like a wee ale that you can go down.
Uh, Roy. And then I can buy dice. What's the dice?
Oh, good. How much?
And cleanser? Storm. What the hook? Oh, flying saucers. That's what we alien discs.
Flying saucers. Yeah, they got a sherbet on the inside. New business idea, convention.
There should be a booth where someone sprays you with deodorant while VTuber berates you for being
stinky. I always thought that idol, like the Japanese idol, like meat ingredients are so
cute because they like hold your hand and stuff. And they like look you in your eyeballs and that.
Sorry, I keep losing five cents every time I do that, but I'm not familiar with your funny American
money. Right, fifth day and then one, two. Okay, that's it. Fifth day and one, two. I'm just over
complicating it. Um, I think I might be a woman. I sit with my legs crossed without popping them.
Is that popping your legs? I'll say it again. Those ladies are too attractive for this show.
Lining. Hydration check. Oh my God. No, don't pay me money to. Yes, I will drink, but don't give me
money for them. Thank you crazy, Jesse. And thank you. Don't give me money. Just say hydration.
You can just type hydration check. You can just type hydration check. Okay. If you hit the wrong
angle, pop. You're winky. Oh, you pop your balls. Oh, is that what you mean when when guys say like,
oh, if I sat like that, I'd sit on my wee balls. Um,
um, Linnie's engineering. Do you prefer cola with or without?
Not only are you stinking up my shop, you're stinking up my counter.
Um, I'm going to have to restock soon, but no one's buying anything. So I can't restock it.
Um, I prefer cola from the fridge with no ice. I wouldn't put ice in it normally. I just drink
straight from the can. Oh, for some reason, glass cola tastes better. Glass cola tastes better,
right? I need to fill up these shelves. My goodness. Can you buy it? Okay. They're bought the card,
so we unlock the next task. The task is in the top left. Thank you very much. You are the little
man. Okay, I'm getting there. Successfully complete 100 checkout. Well, people aren't
even buying, so is anybody looking at me? Oh, live spiral reaction. Thank you for the 10
gifted memberships. Congrats to those who cut them with your face. Please enjoy your emotes.
Yes, there's a pregnancy mode. No, I will not explain further. I listened to my pregnancy,
ASMR. I'm so sorry. I shouldn't have looked up the codes. Like, I looked up a very unique, um,
ooh, big spender. I looked up an incredibly unique plot the other day. And now,
I don't think I was, I kind of want to be pregnant with you again. I don't know how to say it.
Insert minecraft bot. Oh, again, all that XP. Hi, Riflin. Would you like to buy anything else?
I'm so sorry. There's nothing on that shelf. I am so sorry. It's just a, it's a misinput.
I think maybe I'll put the card thing there and then I'll put the shelves over there.
See, if I start as the next day, I'd be missing out on these sales. A dollar, 20. Right, you come over
here and then you, you don't, yeah, you don't really need like, okay, not to cost of the door though.
I guess we'll do an ale. Oh, sorry. Wait, queue to move it, then rotate.
I kind of want to like separate the playing area. Are you squiddin' me right now?
So you have a bit of privacy, like at the playing area. So it's like,
you're not on display, like you have your own little bit here and then we can open up like a
little self-serve ramen bit in it as well. We love staring into the void. It's such a
comfort. I really like it. I don't know, like I'm so tempted to do it again. I want to do it again.
Right, can I order? Thank you. Messed up BrainSpeak for the membership
and thank you again, Live Spiral Reaction for the gift.
I seem to make way, oh no, I was going to buy days, wasn't I? I still didn't have enough for days.
What's this, then? 150? Brov booster packs is.
I'm too poor. My fellow Americans, I shouldn't have done that.
All I can do is buy one.
And the delivery, wait, what? I'm not going to make it. Only guy she mass, I'm not going to make it.
It was so comforting, would love a sequel. Oh, I'm so good. No, I definitely, like I was
listening to my ASMR yesterday, like my newest video that came out. I was getting nice comments.
Actually, someone sent a really nice marshmallow about it. You know who you are.
They were like, I know you don't, I know you worry like about, oh my god, thank you for
letting me pop your super cherry as well. Live Spiral Reaction. Someone left the marshmallow.
I didn't expect it. They were just like, I know you get worried that you're not doing real ASMR
when you do your ramble stuff, but it literally quietens my brain so much when I listen to it,
because you're like very clearly passionate about whatever you're rambling about, even though like
you're supposed to be like whispering and quiet and relaxing, but you get so excited you speed up
type thing. And it was really nice. And I'm like, oh, I'm like, shit, if you want more rambling ASMR,
like one, I don't have to prepare a script. The only thing, please don't come behind the
counter, sir. The only thing I would say about it is it takes longer to subtitle. Like if you
look at the subtitles in that video that just came out, you can tell it took a hot second to
like get anywhere with it, to get anywhere with it. Because I was putting like we notes in it.
We like things that are hidden. So like if you didn't watch the video, there's like a few things
with the subtitles like me making little jokes and all that. Honestly, you're laughing make your
yapping makes EP. But thank you again, live spectrum. I'm just smashing your name together.
Live sparrow reaction for the bra. I cannot do math and talk at the same time.
For the gifted memberships and the tip on top as well. I really love to listen to it. It feels
like I'm just chilling with my friend and my license company. Yeah, it's really nice because
I love to prepare and like, I don't have to retake things either. Like when I do a roleplay,
I'll do a few retakes on sentences. Like I don't know if maybe I should. Oh no, I've shown
one example. I don't know in what ASMR roleplay it was. I started at the start, but I purposely
left it in just to show you like what it's kind of like for me. A wee bit. Like it's a little very
boring. I listened to it on repeat for a couple hours sitting at my desk and then I fell asleep
to it when went bed two. It didn't work. I would say I'm worried if you listen to ASMR at work,
it'll put you, bro, no one's buying in. Everyone get the fuck off the tables and buy shit. I'm like
stuck on this task. No one's buying. Thank you crazy Jesse. Please stop going behind the
counter. Do I need to move the counter? For the super chat. Yeah. The, oh my God, please,
can I come out with a sentence and do math at the same time? Right there. Take it. And I
never even got to the end. I just fall asleep before every time. See, that's the kind of ASMR
roleplays I like making where you never even find out what the ending is. Some people have asked for
like a one hour roleplay where I do talk through the whole thing and I'm like, it's intimidating,
but I'm not being funny. I will do anything you ask for because I'm getting really excited to finish
up like editing the recorded ASMRs. So then we can come up with plots that you want for the reward
system. Because I would like, how am I shop level five? I feel like I'm doing this just standing here.
Yeah, he's just watching over. He's conveying them. He's a conveyance though.
Anything? Anything? I don't know. I just like making content you guys actually want to see
versus just taking a shot in the dark. Because the next, the next,
the next one's just ear brushing, no talking. Like I got, it's like, I'm moving in it visually,
but there's nothing said in it. And it's like, I'd rather make stuff that you guys genuinely
want to hear and see. And it makes me happier doing it that way. Sometimes I listen to ASMR
when I need to go shopping and my social anxiety acts up. It's so embarrassing if people could hear.
I think it's just, whatever makes life easier for you, like, I hope like you don't actually
feel like ashamed or anything for it. Like whatever makes life easier because life is tough enough
of it. I'm sorry about that actually. See you later. Who would that make? Checkmate. Who would that
make ASMR? Did he fart? Wait, what did that just hear? Did someone just, did I hear an infarct?
No, I think it's the music. Sorry. Sorry. I think there's some sort of music thing going on.
It sounded like Brian farted at the end of that text to speech. I'm so sorry. I was like, who's
farting? Xerion, thank you for the tip. I don't know how I would do the,
I don't know how would you do, I could do a wedding night. ASMR, but I'd be getting off
the load would be peeking the audio. It would ever smelt at Delta. Oh my god, I've not heard that in
years. Whoever rhymed it, climbed it. This is tempting. Inspires me that you take feedback
because it just says you're still willing to grow. Yeah, I'd like, so I prepared some content before
debut, but I wrote in membership streams, I write what the refillings want on Patreon, and it just
feels so much more fulfilling when like that audio comes together because I'm like, oh my god, they,
they wanted it. Plop, plop, plop. Okay, we can buy dice. Tab, right, escape the counter. Tab,
stock order. Dice, one please, even though it's, I'm a, what's 21 take away seven? 14 cent short
because of the delivery fee. Okay, I will wait until someone does something. Order, stop. I'm
trying so hard, okay. Whoever pointed the finger, did the zinger? I've never heard that. Reverse
comfort roleplays are probably my favorite, where the listener helps ASMR. Oh, that's cute.
I don't know how I would do that though. I just come to you when I'm really bummed out,
and then you just play with my hair, and I get to put my head on your chest,
or maybe your tummy, because your tummy all nice and squishy. All I need is
Moments company, the rest is all just bonus. Mommy, I want my dice. I'm trying so hard. I literally
need someone to buy like, oh, there you go. There you go. There you go. I got your dice. Look, I got
your dice. I got your dice. Jingle, jingle, jingle. Okay, let's see what's going on here.
Uh, let's pop them here. Actually, I probably should have put them there. No, can I put you
back in the box? Okay, the dice and miscellaneous items are going to go on this one. Oh, wait,
there's more in here. Is there more? The box has no item in it. Okay, there's no more. Right,
let's see what the dice, what are you? Market price is 18 while we're undercut slightly.
Oh, they are the 20 die. Good afternoon. Thank you for waiting. Sorry,
I was just restocking the shelves. You know what it's like one man army.
Hardly working or working hard. Yeah. All yours. All yours. Thank you.
Mm hmm. Examples are re, rescuing a cat girl or something.
Scottish onomatopoeia, ASMR. What's onomatopoeia?
Where is the room? See, it even has the break room. This is the same developers. It even has
the break room. Like, come on, this is literally where let me in. Let me in. I need door. I don't
have door handle jiggle.mp3. How about we just play an ego sound? Let me in. Let me in. Or how about that?
Yeah.
Me when I can't open the door to the reef lens.
One, two, one, one. Thank you for waiting. Good luck in your booster pack. I wish you
all the pools that you could ever ask for. Okay, the shelves are like fucking embarrassing. Holy
crap, I need to. Now, I'm going to suggest something. If you move a little to the left,
or you move a little to the right. Mm. Oh no, you both need to go left because you're facing the
same way. Sorry. Right, tab or, or dare. And then, how is that 91? Am I going mental?
Oh, no, I have 91 bucks. Bro, my shelves are barren. Vampire's squid girl needs a blood
feeding. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Maybe. Right, what was that other thing we could buy? Accessories?
Oh, 159, aren't you? A deck box, red, more 20s. Shop level seven required. A collector's book?
Oh, I guess if you're pulling cards, that makes sense. So this is as much cards as we can pull.
Okay, je comprends. Figures are 500. It's a bit of an investment, right? I think cleanser's probably
next and then like the different dice types. I'm going to be honest, I'm struggling to pay my bills.
My bills are paying. Do I need more tables? I don't know. I don't, I'd rather they spend money on that.
I mean, look, I get it. The shelves are a bit barren. Okay, they're a bit barren, but I'd rather
they spend money so I can invest it in more products. Like, what was my, I make six, almost
seven dollars profit. Profit is six dollars and then on the weans, it's just under a dollar. Yeah,
I just need, I just need someone. Yeah, like I need you. I need you. You, you, you. You guys
seen Blues Brothers? It's a really good one. I need you. Yeah, yeah. I need you. Okay, that's good.
We can, no, we still can't stock the freaking cleanser thing.
Right, how much is the cleanser? I just want to get it so there's like a variety.
159. Oh, the goose drank wine. I wonder when it cost her on a car shop. It's a shame because
they're all shutting down. Like these independent things are all shutting down. I remember the,
I think three shut down that I knew of from my whereabouts. And like they did, they had the
tables and everything for people to come in and play. Is it this, I think the stink maybe puts
off a new customer? No, she doesn't seem to care. Um, God, I'd be the first. Literally,
this is the storage room that's behind the shop and then I guess you extend into the next building.
Please don't walk behind the counters. Thank you. Don't do that again.
Maybe I'm supposed to be selling booster packs. I don't, I'll put it, can I move it?
Oh, I can. Right, everyone stop coming behind the counter, okay? Because I'll be coming around
the counter when I come. Right, no, hold on. It has to be this, like this, okay? Okay, thank you for
waiting. I think once the shop expands as well, it'll probably look a lot better.
Makima cosplay? When? Taking us for walkies? Oh, is she the one with the yellow eyes?
That always gets drawn with the werewolves.
I like it. That's the only way I know about certain characters. I'm like, yeah, are you
going to come in? No, end of the day. Okay, we have 225, so I'm going to order the smelly stuff. I
don't know what it is. It just says cleansing. Oh wait, I didn't order it. I put it in my car,
but I didn't order it. The werewolves from chainsaw man. Sure, I'll just put it here.
Oh my god, that's so satisfying. Okay, let's make some profit on these bad boys. 16A, let's
undercut the market. Yeah, we make $8.00, $7.00. Everything we make good profit on,
I just need people to come flying in and do it more. I am sold. Yeah, only $21.00.
Played at worse. Revenue income, profit.
I am card earnings. Yeah, well, I don't really sell cards because I wanted to collect them myself,
but I need to make money in order to keep going. Right, this looks like all the little stuff going.
Mommy, are we wimps? Wimpling? Only when I scare you.
Stoney has the perfect assets. Where am I cute? Cosely.
She's the red-haired girl in the business attire. Yeah, yeah, I know her.
Yeah, I'm familiar with her work. Yeah. Okay, hydration check. That's right. I'm
remembered to tell you at Hydra. What the fuck? It's already been an hour 30.
Have I yapped for an hour 30 already? Oh my god. Time flies when you get to yap about the things you love.
I almost charged you a dollar for that. I almost got myself in trouble there.
Geez. I don't know how I do that, honestly. I be time traveling when I stream. I don't know
about you, but I be time traveling. Okay, thank you very much. I would like to give you this, please.
My water out. Oh yeah, your water out. Her work. Oh yes, I'm working, wink, wink.
I'm working. Whoa, we made 50. Oh my god, this place stinks.
Where? I don't see how to clean stuff up. We made 50 on these though. Hold on a minute.
I guess the more expensive the item, the more profit to be made.
Did we do another dice then? I don't have enough though. Maybe.
I'm going to get, I'm going to get one of these. Oh my goodness. Hold on. I'm going to get one of
these because, oh, there's more. I didn't even, oh, oh, bad. Oh, sorry. I just walked into that.
I'm embarrassing that customer. Sorry.
Take a can and use it. Huh? This?
Raffelin. Raffelin, you need to shower more. Don't come to my shop stinky.
Do you understand? That's right. Look down in shame. Don't come in stinky. Wait, I sell the
product again? But it's a used product. Don't I have to put it in the bin?
No, don't say you're pheromone max and naughty boy. Only amelie to pheromone max.
You can solely use cans at full price. That doesn't seem, that seems disingenuous.
Oh my, no, I'm typing it down. Fuck you. I'm typing it down. Girlfriend forces you to stop
pheromone maxing ASMR and I'm just like violently scrubbing you. Bubble sounds. I've literally
wrote that in my notes. Get fucked. My ASMR idea now. Get fucked. Copyright of strong calls
at velour. Gen one indulge. Subscribe to my gen mates. Actually, I'm making that. I don't care.
I'm making that. I'm going to get a commission artwork of me looking angry with a fucking soap
in one hand and a scrub in the other. Girlfriend ends your pheromone max streak real. The power
of Febreze compels you. Honestly. No, I'm making that. See, this is this stuff. This is what I mean.
This is what gives me life when I'm like when I'm mucking about we is and we come up with memes
stuff together. When's the sigma ASMR? Sigma affirmations. I don't know enough about that meme type.
Bye. Whenever I think of sigma, I think of a vermin type too now. Bye sigma. I am compelled.
A great idea. A sigma ASMR rule play would go hard. Wait, what is it though? Hold on.
I'm just going to type in sigma brain rot memes. Sigma brain rot memes and see what happens.
Um, what the sigma?
What's up my 11 year old skibbity riz, brother? Am I right? We actually don't talk like that,
this is brain rot. What? What was this? Did I just repeat what the sigma over and over again
in the ear? Is that what you want? I can do that tomorrow. I just repeat what the sigma.
But I do it like in different ways.
You're a beta, I'm a sigma, roar, growl, growl.
That's what you want. You want me to go in the mic. You're being so skibbity Ohio right now.
You're being such a saucy baka. Then at the end, what is that melody?
The middle card in your hand is triggering me so hard.
The middle card? I don't have card. I don't have card. Are you stream delayed? I don't have card
in hand. Oh, I'm a vtuber model. Oh, you don't like it? It's the one I'm going to pick. It's like
the anime thing where I'm like, I pick a card, any card, any card is your, I'm so sorry. I was
like, what in game? I don't see kind. God, we're still to do 100 checkouts.
Can you guys stop playing with each other?
Like, no, there's no card. You can see there's no cards at the, okay, this is what I want.
How much? Exact change, $77. I'll take it. Thank you.
Wow, so cheap. Okay, so take it all, please. Take it all. Take it all. Thank you, replaying.
Oh, I like you a little mustache. But imagine him with a little taper of faith though.
Thank you. Thank you for your business. One, two, three, one, two, all yours. Oh my God,
gorgeous business. Thank you. You must be Scottish. Thank you. Or Irish, one of the others.
Because you're a ginger. Like, in me.
I can't bite the card. The card isn't my thing. I can't push it down.
Hi, strongy. I'm late, but have you had troves of people come in at once and steal your cards
and trash in place? That's what happens in real life. What, they steal boosters? I heard that.
Oh, I can't remember. I can't remember, but it's like, some places open up.
Some places can open up the cards and then make it look like they've not been open.
Do you know what I'm on about? Like, it's really bad. I've forgotten the terminology for it. It's
not splicing. I can't remember the name of it. All right. This is going to be like a little
booster pack shelf. Okay. And then the other one's going to, no, no, sorry. That's a major booster
pack. This one's going to be the booster pack shelf. So I'm going to fill it up. I just want it
to look more full than it is. Okay. And then this will be all Busturi Worstries. And then the next
one will be all Dacey Wacies. Like this one will be all the Dacey Wacies. And then, I guess,
smelly stuff and something else. Excuse me. Sorry. Sorry. It's a bit of a tight squeeze in the
shop, is it? I'll expand soon. I promise I will. I'll expand soon. 47. Right. One, two, one,
one, one. Sorry. I cannot do maths out loud. So I have to like basically just say one over and over
again. Thank you very much. Here's your two dollars and 60 cent change. Thank you for your
produce. Your produce? Yeah. Your support of my business. Right. We'll get more smelly can.
Maybe this will just be a smelly can rack. Yeah. There's like so many dice though.
Fine. We'll get one of these. No, I'm too poor. Okay. I can't afford it. I tried. I tried. I tried.
But we'll make this accessible. Big boxes. And then these are individual booster packs.
And then the dice. I guess they're coded to check out the cards. And maybe that's why we're not
getting as much sales. But I want to like genuinely try and get all the cards. I don't want to sell
my collection. Like no, I like it. Like look how cool these are. You have like some reverse
hollows and shinies and stuff. I don't want that. I'll just, sorry. Let's not play in the dark.
How does it not just come on automatically? Do a pack opening live? Well, I want to do a Pokemon
pack opening and putting it away in like the sleeves and stuff. I need to order. Stop. Enough
with the brain rot. I need to purchase the book thing that it goes in. You know how there's like
sleeved book decks to protect it? I know. I know. I want to do it. So then we'll open all the cards
and then we'll numeric them. So we put them in the right section in the book as well. I think that
would be really nice. It would be a very long hand cam stream though. And I'd need to definitely
make sure you can see what I see because when I did the pop and cooking stream, I did all right
trying to keep most of it in frame. But it's really difficult because I can't see what you see. I'm
looking down and I'm not looking up at the monitor type thing because I was on the floor during that
stream. And if we do a Pokemon pack opening, I think we'd probably be on the floor again.
Make sure the pages do not reflect your face though. Oh no. You're gonna see what I really
look like. Oh no. Oh, it's getting late. I don't know if someone's gonna be able to play with you.
Right. Stop pheromone maxing this poor lady. No, no, don't move it. Sorry. I mean, take this.
Take this. Take this. Relate. There you go. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You're gonna batter it away,
but you know I'm right. You're well. I'm doing you a favor. I'm doing you a favor. Okay.
A stinkling? Oh, that's so cute. Are you my little stinkling?
Danny, give you a wishy-washy in the bathtub. There's more me need to scrub you all over.
Refresher's doing work. Okay, wear a balaclava and strap a GoPro to your forehead then.
What? What was that response to? You could probably put tape around the area that your camera can't see.
Imagine wearing a balaclava of recling. No. By the way, Momay, you did something to
blow my mind to my brain every time you hear someone say Fortnite and I whisper, Fortnite,
soon. You're gonna know why it's been stuck in my head. I mean, I've already leaked to that. I'm
pretty sure Amy's already spoken about it as well. Girlfriend ties you up and cures your brain raw
ASMR. Lobot me. You guys are on fire today. What the fuck? What the fuck? You guys are on fire.
I've literally just straight copied and pasted that in a minute. Fuck you. My idea now. I'm
profiting off of your hard work. You guys are on fire. I don't know what's going on. I want
Lobot me ASMR. You're getting it. I'm going to do all the brain mashing sounds. I have an idea on
how to make them. How can Strony cure your brain raw? She caused it. How dare you speak the truth
that they hated him for he spoke the truth out loud. Girlfriend ties you up and gives you brain
raw and then afterwards it's like it backfired. This isn't skibbity. I'm so sorry Reefling but
I know what I have to do. This isn't skibbity. Okay, I can finally afford a new dice set. Hello
little package. Are you squinting right now? No, I would never beat you. Mama beats the piss
out of you. No, I don't beat you. I love you. You're my little baby. Let's undercut the market.
Okay, we make seven on that. We make seven on that. Yeah. Five on you. 90. Okay, the price
seems to fluctuate. Let's just say we do make good profit on whatever people do buy. It's just
not to be confused with Dubai. I'm not beating Reefling. The only version of beating you I'll do.
You know those funny video ASMR memes that are beating you unconscious? I would do that.
Oh, I forgot to order the microphone for my stomach sounds ASMR. Hold on. I need to write that
in my notes. Fucking hell, I have more notes in one day than I've had in weeks. Headphone make order
now because I said I was going to do that ages ago. As I said, I do like eventually get around to
doing what I need to do. It's just because it takes time. I want to unlock the figures before I go.
A red deck. I'm wondering if we just skip to a red deck.
So we've got two variations of dice because if I got more dice I would actually need another shelf.
You know that. This is tempting.
Girlfriend buys your favorite packs for $100 a month. No, you didn't like the dice. I'm sorry.
I thought you would have went for it. Okay, no change. Thank you. I feel like 33. Not bad. I'll take it.
I just need you to... I'm needing you to, you know, start. This is tempting, yeah.
No, stop. Danny packs this away. I will. Can I like sell you? Box up. Right, and then place it down.
I like... I don't want to sell the cards. I want them for myself.
I'll sell duplicates, but if the duplicates are like literally $0.10, I'm not...
I'm not giving... I suppose once they're priced, actually. You know what? Don't be...
Don't be lazy. You run a card shop. I'm sorry, okay? I'm sorry for being lazy sometimes. I just...
Oh, you know. I don't want to open up packs either. Like, I want to invest. I want to invest in my junk.
Right, we're going to try you. What are you? The hose is going to love this. It's me on the hose.
Chicky tablet screen? What? Screen? What does this mean?
Right.
Tablet? Winkwink 9000? Tablet screen? Do you mean like brainwalt? Like a... 18...
No, no. Yeah. Only four quid profit?
That's worse than the cans.
This is worse than the cans.
Bro, I'm going to just put my stocks into the cans. How is that so bad?
I don't want to upsell. No, I like being under market value. I want people to shop
independent and when they realize that corporations and all that are bad...
Oh, this changed in price. No, I don't want to have to adjust it every day as well. I'm lazy.
I noticed that in supermarket simulator, it like notified you what items went up and down in price
and I'm like, ah, I'm too lazy to like constantly change it. I'd rather just undersell. I'm sure
that's probably what I'm doing wrong. I'm sure everyone's like going above like the recommended
market price or something and then then here's me like, I just can't seem to get enough money to
invest. What's going on? A reef link here. I don't know.
Scrolling for five hours. So it's just silent breathing. Almost $20,000. There's an only making
four profit. Girlfriend whispers subliminal messages in your ear while you sleep and make
you addicted to her ASMR. Oh, that's a cute one. I'm not sure. I really like plots where you're shy
to introduce that you like ASMR, but then like, I would be super accepting and like, oh, come on then,
let's have a fun night together type. Fuck it. I'm writing that down as well. Fuck it. Fuck you,
bitch. I'm writing it down. Okay, reef link confesses he likes ASMR. Instead of rejection,
I'm super duper awesome and accepting and then plan one hour ASMR
pampering session and then by the end, I ask how I've done and you're asleep. So we cuddle and
sleep together and I give a forehead kiss and then there's a soft breathing section at the end to
sleep to me. Well I sleep with you. That's really cute. I like that. Okay, we're going to do that.
That'll be my first like proper strong collapse with the lure and it definitely isn't her just
mimicking the other girls while she gas lights you into thinking it's not just no, I cannot. I can't
do like I actually really hurts to do my Azura mimic actually really hurts.
Um, it's not anything to do or hurt just, well obviously my voice is a bit sore after my chaos
that ensued and the thingy and yesterday's stream. Um, it actually really hurts to mimic a voice.
Um, like my wee voice box just can't, can't handle it, you know, right? No, come. Yes. And then
what the sigma? Let's just spread them out a little bit.
I have an odd one out. That's okay. Right, speaking us to get you. Come. No. You. Take. Our. Spray.
Put it back and pretend like we never used that.
He he he. That must be one. I love pampering and checking after care. I want to be loved.
That's good. Yeah. I like it. It's a thing of someone holding a tablet at their waist in
bed with the tubers face on screen. Monka. Oh my God. I think I know what you're talking about.
That trend. I know what you're talking about. The rambling ASMR last night and while I couldn't
fall asleep to it, I did find myself zoning out as if I was going in and out. There was
something hypnotic about the fast rambling in one ear and the random tacks moving around.
Oh, you like that. Thank you, Sleepy Phoenix for the tip. Wink, wink, 9000. I know exactly what
you're talking about. Holy moly. Someone did it to pretend to do the gloop, gloop, 9000. And then
she had to delete all her content. I know exactly what VTuber asset you're on about.
It's like you're POV, you're holding a tablet, like your legs are inframing that,
and I would be on the tablet, but because the face would get cut off possibly.
Unless I did like a creepy meta roleplay ASMR where I'm like,
I know you're watching me, Riefling. It's okay. And then like, I just realised,
why did no one tell me the hand is hanging off of me? You've been...
Brett. Is that me? I think I did that. I did not realise my hand was very clearly,
obviously, holding off on the asset like that. You didn't notice? Oh, you just turned it.
Are you two into my eyes? Yes, yes you are. You are into my eyes. 35, gone in.
Right, so we've got Smelly Stuff, Booster Packs, Boxes, we're getting a wee bit small.
That was a waste of freaking money. The dices are selling, but like,
I feel like I'm missing a core mechanic. It must be the cards. I don't want to open and sell cards.
Maybe more dice?
What are you? Level 8? I want to try and unlock this book, I assume,
or should we just try and save up for figures?
$500 for figures. I mean, if I don't spend anything and just completely sell...
Wait, hold on, what does this say? Open phone.
Renault. Shop expansion.
Would that increase the number of customers? Manage event.
Strony's Card Emporium. Standard fee.
Nearby Store Shurch 10, so we'll charge $8. Random Rarity Pack. Confirm event.
Did I do it? Bells!
Bells.
Bells. Okay.
Can you open the box? Possibly. Take item.
Okay, they don't count. It has to be the booster packs only. I mean, I guess that makes sense,
because that's what the fun is. Right, we're gonna save up $500 and we're gonna try and sell plushies.
I'm wondering if I had more tables and chairs. Would more customers be assigned to the shop?
Oh, decisions. Decisions. We're guessing about how the AI is set up in this thing.
Decisions. Decisions.
All right, we're gonna sort by amount. Do I have any duplicates?
No, I sold them all. Okay, Momie Yandere ASMR. You dox the streamer, so she breaks in and lives with you.
Many refling heights. He loves being pampered by Momie. He controls and opens them up.
Oh, I'll open you up on it. Sorry. Sorry. Ed stop. Let me pop the lights on,
because we're still playing. Can't even read the name of the cards.
Girlfriend comforts you after a thing, after a scary movie. ASMR roleplay,
comforting your stalker, looking through your webcam. Comforting your stalker? No, your stalker
comforts you. I would have to be your stalker. No, I'll open you up. I mean, what?
Bro, that's literally me. I'm like, yeah, after I'm done, you how? More tables and chairs would get
more pays per hour. It is. Okay, we're learning the AI. Okay, how much is the table and chair?
I think it's like 30, 300 though. No, wrong one. Sorry, that one.
That's fucking blinding. I just want you to know my eyes didn't even know.
Right, so we're gonna get more folk in. I mean, definitely. Oh, no, I wanted the plushie. Oh,
I've already forgot. I want $500 for the plushie. Look, we're gonna expand the shop soon. I promise,
we're gonna expand the shop soon. I need, I just want $500 so I can get the plushie. I just want
to see the plushie. We got $30 just from them sitting playing games. Are they tipping? Is that
what you do in cart? I've never played in a card shop before. Do you tip for being there? I thought
like when you buy card packs or when you buy food items, like I assume they have dry snacks there.
Boss teases you while at work ASMR. I don't think that's for YouTube if I'm writing that one.
They pay $8 for playing. Oh, did I do the event?
Current game event. Is it on? I'll find out when it's shot. When it closes.
Yeah, little dice set. Good choice. $1.50, sir. I'm gonna keep it a Costco hotdog.
They probably have gamer subs there. Yeah, you need, where's my gamer subs? I don't see it.
Use code SRANI for 10% out. All right, anyone. There is a new flavor, new
variation of anime thighs and guess who's thighs are on it? Shibis. I keep doing that. I would like
to pick up the product and then stop it. You're stinking at this place. Yeah, I got the behind
the scenes opportunity. And I was very surprised. I was like, oh, damn, you want to see it? Because
we had only just got signed on. And forks agency was like, I have this opportunity. And I'm like,
Oh God, whose thighs do I give it to? Because I had to pick it up. Everyone's thighs. And I said,
you know, they told me what the packaging was like. And I was like, right, so we need sex. So
thighs. And it was between Mercy's thighs and Shibis. But because Shibis has Shabari rope on it.
And I ended up picking her. But obviously, Shibis wasn't tan at that point. I'm going to let them
finish playing because I'll get money for it. But kinklings rise up. Gotta let them know use code
SRANI. Yes, this is before Sheepsters was tan. It takes a while for that line of production
stuff to come through like that. Obviously, I don't know anything about it. But that stuff
that you got to do a couple of months in advance. So Sheepsters wasn't tan yet.
But yeah, because she had the Shabari ropes on her legs, I picked her. It was between her and
Mercy. And the song design on Mercy was too much to ask for. Obviously, I didn't put myself forward
because, you know, I want the girls to have the opportunity, not me. But no, Gamersops have
been fantastic. I need to message them because I've got a PR package from them and all that.
I'm just going to ask them, you know, how much am I allowed to say in there? Oh,
he's done. He's buying anything or he's gone home? Not he's gone home, right? I'm so sorry,
but no one's available to play. I can't play either. Right, we've got a new table. So
total visits 15. Keep that in mind. 15 is the magic number. We're bought a new table. So
if all of a sudden we start getting thingy, Azur's thighs wouldn't fit. No, it had to be
Azur, although Azur's, everyone's, no, don't get it twisted. Everyone's is gorgeous, lovely
10 out of 10 design, all of that. It just, someone had to be picked. And it was between either
Mercer or Shibi. And Shibi got it because of the Shibari ropes, just due to the nature of the
design. Like, it's just how it went. Stop looking at the cards. I'm not saying, stop shaking your
head at it. You can see it's empty. I'm not selling cards. I want to collect them myself,
you fannies. Honestly, like, did I need to rip packs open and just sell the duplicates?
I don't even think I'm going to make a profit that way. I need someone to man the till.
But I can't hire a reflin yet. How did I make 16 bucks on 110?
They want to buy cards. Oh, I'm going to have to rip cards open.
Strony and Dairy Hacks, your speaker system and toxies are electronic, so you sleep to get
Stockholm Syndrome. You want me, you want more of me, you need me. And she like,
literally, she's like, distinctly, one distinct please. I'm like, uh, sure.
Sure. Just buy one box for yourself. I think I'm going to have to, literally,
they're getting a sign to buy cards. I think that's what the problem is. That's what the,
the hold up, what's the whole, whoa, no, that's a big overcharge.
Point eight. You can like, type it on the number pad. I'm pretty happy with that.
A dollar, 50. Right, that's it. We're doing it. I don't care if everyone's going to be
staring at me. I'm going to be opening them right in front of everyone. Right, let's go.
Let's go. Okay. Hit him with a new one. Hit him with a, ooh, ooh.
Why are we getting like, so many, sounds like a Lillipop, that one actually. It looks like
Lillipop and Lucari put together. Oh my God, that's exactly what the, looking thing is.
Are we baby? Are we star? What's a star?
Is that Houdini's eyes mixed with the legendary feral bird? It's not feral. It's the other one.
These are fucking fucking mashed together. I, I find it hard to, I don't know. I don't know about
you chief. Like that was supposed to, the last one was supposed to be the orange fish that only
knows splash. I'm going to sneeze. No, that's literally, like it's that bear that has the
circle on its belly and then Azuba. Like, come on. Am I, am I going mental? I can't even,
well I could be going mental, but Magikarp, that's him. Guppy. Oh my God, we got one of three for
Guppy. Yay, we can fly soon. That's a reference to the hit video game. Yeah, it's like telling me
the cards total are like more than the base price of the packet, but I don't know.
I'm not getting anything. If there's like a billion cut, I'll need to open up the thing
you can see how many cards there are, but like, I ain't getting any cut. These are the same over
and over again. It must be because it's the, it's not the full game on launch. Oh, we got a shiny
sapling. Your new Tetron, I don't know what you're based after. But yeah, I'm so sorry,
that customer just staring me in the background whilst I'm like holding up the cards physically,
like like two centimeters away from her face. Nimbless. Yeah, like, how is that new? I've seen
that. It must be variations, like shinies and reverse hollows and all that jazz and backflips
in 360s. And thank you for waiting. Thank you for just thanking yourself.
It's a variant with better skills. She's getting our free show.
Well, my girlfriend, Pamper June forces you to take your meds, but she disappears. Oh,
no, that's so sad. I feel like that's a mean one. I don't want to actually, I don't want to make one
that could be interpreted as mean when I'm, I don't, whoa. Wait, what? Right, give me that.
And close album. Yeah, since you're all crying about how I've never sellin' cards,
I don't know why everyone's so interested in these like, we shake cards, but sure, knock yourself out.
I don't know, like, literally the rubbish. Oh my god, can you pheromone max somewhere else, please?
I'm trying so hard right now to put the shop together. And the first thing you do is come
right next to me. Stink up the joint. Right. I don't know, maybe I can put a higher premium on
cards because they're like supposed to be like, that's what they do when you're missing a card,
right? You like, go to a shop that sells that individual card. Oh, I'm like, some profit,
60 for contents. Like, I'll just put a premium on them. If people start complaining, like,
bro, that's on you. I don't know why you want to buy single. Yeah, I'm making money when they
sit down. Right, we're almost at 500. Do not buy anything. I must only buy. Oh my god,
she be sick and is doing a nap with your six girlfriend to our space? Is she gonna fart?
Is she gonna toot? You don't understand. I hope she feels well soon. Yeah,
due to her sheepster, she's even struggling. We're getting AC sick as well. Emmy was sick.
I think she's still sick. Mercy was sick the other day. Oh my gosh. Everyone's dying. Right,
no, don't stink up the joint. You already know. You already know. Give me that. Stop it.
Stop pheromone maxing. Get out of here. All the girls are sick. Literally,
everyone's getting sick. Is that real? Do you have to pay to play cards at a card shop? I don't
think so. I thought you kind of like paid by, yeah, really breaking the bank there. Like,
nine fucking pens. Do I just need to roll a double of like a card that's valuable, maybe?
It must be because like, bro. We ain't making much profits with this one. That's all I'm saying.
A whole dollar. I don't know. It depends on the shop. Also, your shop has an event going on.
Does it constantly just keep rolling? Bro, I want...
I want the plushie. I'm not paying my bills. I want the plushie. Sorry.
Give me the plushie. I'mma just watch them play. I want the plushie. That's all I want. That's all
I ask for. It's the ability to buy the plushies and sell them. Where are they?
Level six required, so we're gonna get it. Yeah, I just need people to pay a few more things.
MTG often have draft events. Thought just a lot of the issues of people coming in with
$1,000 decks and being unbeatable. You can... Wait, I thought the whole point of like that
kind of stuff is you can't like pay to win.
Did they do like exclusive cards that only a limited set amount of people can have access to?
That can't be right. That doesn't sound right. No plushies until the bills are paid. No, plushies first.
Look, I'm a girl, okay? Scottish bully pins you against the wall with your wrist above your head
and kisses you. If only YouTube allowed it, I would do that, but YouTube has been so freaky.
Bonnie from Globy got a warning on her ASMR. Yeah, YouTube just do not f-ing like ASMR at all
at the minute and they're just no saying a thing. Sorry. I know I keep repeating myself.
It's just really frustrating. It's a frustrating topic, okay? I want to do all these fun plots.
I want to do all these outrageous things. For talking about tea, she posted the clip.
They flagged her for... Yeah, every timestamp is like something ridiculous. The AI is no having it.
The AI is not having it. I do not know why. As I said, obviously, Amy got done for rat sniffing
the mic and you know what they say when YouTube are like, and we take into consideration all the
content on the channel and they're like, you're telling me, Amy's sitting and playing five nights
at Freddy's and it's like... Oh, that's like, you're sick and I look after you and I'd be like,
and then you hear like chopping in the background because I'm chopping up the veggies,
but like you're fading in and out of sleep because you don't feel well. The way that stood erect,
that was impressive. Like you're fading in and out of sleep and I like put little notes on the screen
and it's like, oh, you're... Please don't... I thought she's going to do what I think she's going to do.
Stap it. Stop it. Yeah, I'm targeting you specifically. I think start cleaning.
Thank you, CrazyJC, for the super chat. That would be really sweet and
beaten YouTube to ask this somewhere. What is your opinion on emotionally some of our strong
emotions like sadness that are happy about like getting saved or saving an accident? Oh,
I get wary of touching anything that's too real or maybe too deep because
I just like to focus on like the fun, the happy, the meanie, or you get something out of it type
stuff. Oh my god, I'm like four dollars away from the plushies. I get nervous about actually touching
hard-hitting subjects because I just fear that like someone might take it the wrong way or think
I'm making fun of it because it's like, if I did a super serious video and then they subscribe and
they click on my channel, what did they see? Pregnancy ASMR. And they're going to be like,
oh my god, this person's just like taking the piss and they're like, no, I'm just,
I'm just like being super duper serious.
Right, we'll go... Give me it. Give...
I'm not level six yet. Okay, so what do I do instead?
If I'm not level six,
I don't want to pay my bills. I don't want to pay my bills.
You could also record the sounds from actually cooking you soup.
I was going to do my sweaty feet on kitchen floor tiles ASMR because like mine go like...
Because I got sweaty feet. Did I mention I'm sweaty feet at any point?
Did I mention them? Yeah, you know that that, yeah.
Right, so I can't get any more from that.
I can get more cleanser. I might as well... Oh my god.
I mean, what's that? 500? Right, I'll buy all of that. Oh, well, there you go. I just popped.
It just popped.
Why not? Let's see what I'm looking at. Right, booster packs. Let's get them all up.
Foot bro's winning question mark.
Mommy, I'm so sleepy. Thank you for today's stream.
He's gonna keep... Yeah, this is just a very casual and relaxed kind of day.
We're taking it easy. Why? No, I don't want to randomly take out that in the middle of this.
The box has no items. Oh, that was a perfect resource then.
Yeah, no. Today, very casual and easy and EP. I'm going to be...
Wait, I guess I'm gonna have to put them here? Oh, fine. Well, then give me that then.
Yeah, we're just taking it easy because I don't know what tomorrow's stream is though.
What was that master quote from that one kung fu panda?
Tomorrow's a mystery. Today is a present because it's a gift or something like that.
Wait, so that's $10 profits. In theory, the higher price, like the higher tier is better,
but I'll let them finish playing. Get a better shop, literally. I don't know, maybe extend...
I'm gonna expand it. That's what I'll do next. I'll expand the shop size and put more tables down.
How about that? That seems logically what we're supposed to do next.
Cult of the Lamb. It wasn't tomorrow given the reflands no gamertag. No, everything's
being shifted around. I'm having a particularly hard thing right now. I'm shuffling things around.
I think Cult of the Lamb's getting swapped out. The membership streams are getting delayed as well.
Tomorrow is a mystery. Yesterday is history, but today is a gift. That's why it's called the present.
That's the other god you remembered.
You understood the reference I was making. So I have my random seven board up right now
for all the things. Master Oogly. Sorry, my... I wouldn't have. I have Viral's Curse, Fortnite,
Chug Jog. I have the cough.
Reflings when I tell them that I want to spawn the high table.
Oh no, reflings when they realise I wasn't joking about taking down the high table.
Horses are gonna fix the economy. Trust. Trust. Have faith. If I ever win the lottery,
just know that I ain't depressed and I'm never gonna kill myself.
Okay, day eight.
Does any pay am I late for rent? Is the shop gonna expire?
The rent... I owe 421 bucks. No.
Each day on light usage in the shop. So what, just leave it off?
I can't even hire you yet. I don't have much experience but I'm willing to learn and do
anything. Oh, you are a reflin. Please hire me because I need the money to pay for art school.
You're creative? You are creative. Did you come up with ASMRs and tell me what to do?
Two bucks for this. It's fair, isn't it not astoundingly good? Yeah.
Right, we're gonna expand. I don't know what's gonna happen when we need to pay rent but I'm gonna
just pretend we don't. We're gonna expand and then surely we're gonna get tons of more customers
frequently because I don't get it. I don't get it. Obviously this isn't the finished version of the
game as well. It comes out next. Is it November it comes? I think so. It comes out in November.
It's when it comes out so good. I'm absolutely sorry. I keep typing to get the fucking change.
You didn't hear that? Have you heard that on my keyboard? No, you didn't. I typed in the change to
give. A stinkling spotted? Okay. You only have depression and female illness because with nurse
you'd be taken over the world. I don't have depression. I got the other one. I got the A bomb
but we don't say we don't say we have A bomb. Okay, the stinkling has been fixed.
You look stinky. I can fix that. You look like an honorable card player.
Oh no, you look like an honest card player. I fixed it.
As the hours pass I will let you know that I need to look for me for I'm alone.
Wait, I'm saying the lyrics wrong.
I finally listened to that album by Mr. Kitty the other day when I was all up in my feels and I
was like no, that was definitely the best banger from it. Girlfriend begs for forgiveness after
gambling. Your belongings a smart car go by in the background because you're on the street.
No, don't start singing the song that video instead. All right, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry,
sorry, sorry. Happy song. Happy, happy, happy.
We feeling asleep deprived so mummy cuddles and whispers to him until he sleeps. Oh, it's cute.
I like drag you away from work and because you're so sleep deprived that's cute. I'm copying
that as well. That's a really sweet plot. God, there's so many notes today. Do I know how many
notes that the last notes I had were from seven days ago and today I have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight notes today alone. You guys are on fire. I don't know what you snorted.
Was it my game or something?
But yeah, I love sad music. I need to be careful if I listen to sad music because I can make myself
sad, listen to it. But if I'm already sad while I listen to it, I'll just cry when I listen.
Like I was crying listening to the Mr. Kitty album and I was like, yes, I feel very...
Like what's the word when you get it out your system? Like that. That's what I felt like I was
getting. Right, we're going to open up the shop. How big is a kid? What the fuck is...
Are you trolling me?
A cube.
$300 for a cube expansion. I've got bills to pay. Are you trolling?
A cube? Thank goodness I didn't put my stonks into a...
I mean, I guess I'll work with a Leo, but seriously. Oh my god, I can't even fit.
What? Well, I put the thing here instead.
Is that it?
I'm being trolled.
$300 per square foot? I literally have never been played so hard. What?
What? No, don't look at that.
Oh my god, this rotate. Why have you done only rotate one way?
Oh, I can scroll. Oh my god, I can scroll. I don't have to hit R, dammit.
I don't know what to say.
I tried so hard. Not enough change given.
Oh, 19 bucks on top. Sorry.
I'm afraid I might be taking the L on this game.
I mean, we'll probably play again. No, you know what? We'll get the plushie.
I refuse to get off until I get the plushie.
Right, we're about to be level six, so we just need... Right, stop buying.
Stop it. Right, I'm level six, so I just need $500 to reduce.
Is there, like, do a mount, right, and then do next page,
and then whatever looks most... A whole $16, $0.16, you shouldn't have.
No, seriously, you shouldn't have. Knock off.
Right, we're just... Oh, a whole dollar.
Wait, so I have to price it, I guess?
Oh god, the value of these cards is different as well.
I'm not selling my expensive pools either. I want a full deck.
Look, I'm just... I'm just trying my best, okay?
Right, we're doing an upcharge on the cards because these...
These prices are killer. We're doing upcharging.
You can all be mad that I'm upcharging, but literally I'm making nothing.
Don't complain or I'll fart on you.
Stop it. I'll make you sniff my armpits after a good game.
And actually, I never said this yesterday.
You know when I went for a pee during the overwatch stream?
I sat down and got a waft of myself, like, my armpits, and I was like,
Hey, you! I never said it because I was like,
Oh, did anyone know that I'm sinking?
Don't worry, I've had a shower since, but literally I was like,
Oh, is that me? Jeez.
Um, they really stink.
Don't try and answer a good thing.
It'll literally...
Firm on Biomax.
Right, what is this event thing?
I think I need to do... what?
That event?
Confirm event.
Sure, go nuts everyone.
I think I'm... the phone's only half charged.
It's due in one day, so does the shop shut down?
If I try and go for a push?
I'm not turning the lights on.
Sorry, I ain't got the money.
Literally, we seem to have like four or five customers at a time.
Oh, they're more common, but they don't really seem to be going nuts for it, you know?
Oh, I keep taping in to give the...
Stop it.
It's making a mockery of me.
I need 500.
One of my favorite sad songs is Paralyzed by N.F.
I'm not heard of.
Pet Bro's winning so hard right now.
Yeah, I need to start up in my insult game.
It's no longer farting, it's you have to lick my like armpits after a good gaming session.
Go in Mr. Krabbs mode for the plushie.
SpongeBob me, boy.
Soon, Mummy will have her own green aura appropriate.
It's like I'm a ward.
Strongie, please.
Well, I keep saying I'm going to fart on your eyelashes.
Need to mix it up a bit, okay?
That's fable, Mummy.
Thank you.
That's what I'm saying.
I need to actually give you something to be fear of, okay?
And a big sweaty, be all lick.
All 9,000 taste buds taken in the aura.
Taken in the scent, the musk, the pheromones.
Mr. Krabbs is right, SpongeBob me, boy.
Tingle, tingle, tingle.
Every time you tingle me, boy, you'll have to give me a dollar.
Yes, that's how Mr. Krabbs is my friend.
Okay, now you're waiting to play.
You guys are waiting to play.
Like them so hard they'll be smooth for years.
No, take these back, please.
Don't tease us like that.
Girl's smell is real and reeflings need it.
Yeah, why is, I need to do the reefling,
I need to do the boy smell copy faster,
but I need to edit it so it's like reefling.
Is that your tentacle I smell?
Reefling, I smell it.
Don't try and hide it from me.
Yeah, basically I need to do my version of boy smell,
but it's tentacle eyes.
My tentacle always is so hard.
Wow, thank God that didn't go through.
Almost scammed you there.
Sorry, reefling.
It's like, it's supposed to be the end of my shift.
What's going on?
Okay, that worked.
Before anyone complains about the lights being off,
look, I'm just trying to get,
I'm just trying to plushy max right now.
I'm halfway there.
Come on.
I know, I know it's hard to read.
Right, we made $18 off this.
No, see, when the AI does that where they don't kiss,
right, no one complain about the lights.
I know it looks so shady.
You know you want to come into the back of my shop, okay?
Yes, you do.
Yes, look, your window shopping.
Look at the cards that you can get.
And then you peek back
and you see people in the dark playing cards together.
Yes, you see all the booster packs as well at the top shelf.
Yes, we are opening up.
I'm like sliding across the glass.
All you hear is like,
as I'm sliding across the glass checking out my shop.
Are you gonna sit with that guy?
Nope.
Nope, you're shaking your head at that.
I don't know why.
You gonna buy a nice $0.20?
Thanks, I really appreciate it.
In the back of the shop?
Why yes, of course.
Tried by Mummy in the car shop,
but he's for when?
No, bro, you are glowing.
you are glowing! stop it! there is no way you're glowing that much in my shop
can they even finish the game in the dark? i feel really bad right now that they're having to play
in the dark. he's radioactive. glass squeaking in den of the vise. oh literally glowing.
come on. are you gonna play together? okay nice!
we have f- this is the first time we've had three tables play at the same time
this will never happen again in history
this will never happen again
can they not- i don't think they can finish if the lights are off you know that
i'm sinking, i'm sinking
there come the- what tables? literally the guy's really bumping
so is this them doing it now?
okay yeah they can't finish the game if the lights are off
right right i understand
another really sweet kinda sad song is the acoustic version of wake up by kohid and cambria
i'm not sure i know that one
so that yeah the clocks froze at nine but they seem to still be going through their wee animation
okay yeah there you go it is the candy oh there you go
would anyone like to buy anything before you go home?
oh see it was worth the wait we're gonna get a plushie
oh no she's not well
then i'll redirect into emmy if she's streaming the earth
if not it's mercy
bum bum bum bum bum
this is a razon
oh wait
is that- is that person in the corner?
oh no he walked out okay i'm just
okay so the customers have gone up total visits for 21 now
right
sus
day nine
so what does my phone say now?
about my bill
drew today
and what happens if i don't pay them?
what happens if instead i bought a license to sell plushies?
you ever thought about that?
because i could do it
now you can start putting them together
yeah let's put them all together
you don't really realize how barren the shelves are until you start kind of shuffling things around
a little bit- whoopsie
oh i'm open sorry income
i'm open i was just rearranging some stuff to make it look like we have stock when we don't
what if i want them to try
i pressed the middle button on my phone and it said what do you mean?
wait
oh no i'm yawning
mercy has a members today
i must be-
emmy has a public one?
can i redirect into emmy?
okay
can you buy something not worth five cents?
that would be justy and gushy and lovely okay
ooooh
look at them see
oh wait you wanted me to cosplay her and look she walks in
i know her shoes aren't like that and her hair isn't quite like that but come on
close enough close enough
em
mercy stream today is supposed to be a member but i think it's public
oopsie
well message her
hold on
oh just message her
i'm gonna wait- i hope i don't wake her up
i always get nervous when i message the girls that they like wake them up because
they've got discord notifications on
just checking
your stream today is a member or public
it's public right now for everyone
just in case it's meant for members only it will love you
done and done
wait you talk to the girls like that yes yes we see i love you to each other
surprise me the girls are very nice to me
and they're like oh i love you and i'm like no i love you
yeah fun little detail that i didn't expect they all call me mummy
i never expected that um i think shevi was the first one to call me mummy
like mume like a riflin mummy and they all just kind of call me mummy now and i'm like
i don't know how to feel about this
but it's very cute
probably can't watch it's five in the morning
hey it's a new model yeah that's what i was thinking
like if your shop increases in level do they spawn new people
three dollars not a very good session they already reached quite and they're out
they're like nine buying none of this stuff
she be yeah how surprising that she calls your mummy too
you've been calling them your daughter since the view it's probably natural
no but they call me mummy like m-u-m-m-e-h that's what probably surprised me when we started
interacting with other v-tubers as they were calling me mummy like that too and i'm like
how do you know about that i'm like uh how are we how are you doing that
you know because how do you how do you what's going on what's going on here
how do they know worldwide mummy which i'm like what's going on here how do you know that
i think what it is is maybe for the v-tubers that you know don't know the previous or they
probably don't realize what that i came from there and it's just like why can't i get a
want in the store brah you made the comment so passively that i couldn't even read it in time
and in comes a fair a fair one maxi i need to buy more booster packs actually
i need 200 in order to sell the plushies but i unironically might need to invest in stock before
it none of change given
what is there what the fuck am i okay you know right that's six day make it six day give it a
ten give it five i'll fuck it just have the dollar can i be our smith please do not watch over the
female players sir sir please don't please don't stink over the girls that are playing i i get it
i get it it's rare girl card gamer's rare but sir please don't stink over their table
mummy has been officially trademarked by sharoni literally what makes this funnier is you're
probably younger than most i can't see cannot confirm nor deny
me
to stop it it's literally me oh but i like you watching me
hi refling yeah you like watching yeah you like watching yeah
no don't go away from my kisses you don't want more can i crouch in this game
oh i was gonna crouch but i can't crouch
i need 200 stop see this is why i this is why i didn't want to sell cards because it seems like
such a waste of time he's a shyling i'm going up in them nostrils it's not the only hole i'm going
thank you i was very delayed on that reaction
right uh i guess well
like i could be making a markup i'm not making a mockery of me
that profit was so small on that average cost is 14
is that what the the bigger box thing is is the bigger box you make more money on the bigger
hold on let me analyze stock order so if i buy two units it's
96.55 right 96.55 it's the exact same
okay so then what's the benefit of buying that thing you'd think you'd get a bit of a better
deal on the bulk and then that's kind of the point in buying bulk i'm giving that fucking
plus i'm shoving it i put it in the cart all right i need 206 dollars me millionth dollar
okay we have six people in
what we'll do we'll buy the plus and then i'll wrap it up maybe
can you come back in the shop and order something excuse me sir sir sir sir
fake clean clearly fake clean yeah but as i said this is like literally supermarket simulator
i i don't know if these are like the the reused assets that you can purchase from
um i don't know if you've ever seen those like behind the scenes game dev stuff where you can
use assets like on unity or these kind of things and and it's not an issue and all that
and i'm sure there was a game that came out that had a load of reused assets and everyone was like
don't support this game but and then i was like no actually that's what assets were for you barely
have six hours left to pay your rent i swear if it's game over because i've not paid attention to
the rent because i want this dang plushie
i'll see what happens at midnight i'll see what happened mommy's gonna lose the house
i'm actually is the shop gonna shut down because i'm an idiot it's balut through all over again
i need a big spender like that guy at the start he like came in bought all of the stock and it was
like 117 dollars in one transaction i was like uh yeah right i like when they play a game give me
money and then go get go give me more money because they get like booster packs and stuff
eviction arc we're gonna live under a bridge wait stop you're making me nervous are we actually
gonna is the shop gonna shut down is it not gonna be like your penalties like whatever
yeah you i need more of you reefland come back anytime fuck it come back in the room
right now open this jiggle the handle get us in there come on i need more customers like you
no come back please please come back i need you i want the shop to be successful as long as we're
homeless together he was a youtuber where he was gonna open them on youtube and get his
tax back because he can prove that he used it for entertainment purposes and his business's
entertainment base real answer there is a unity unreal asset store generally you can use them
for commercial just go look up the license yes exactly the back door is priceless hey i'm mama
hi missus do you like the shop so far you like everyone everyone playing cars the lights are
on i'm getting money oh i can buy the piggy oh piggy piggy piggy i got the plushie right what do
you look like and what do you sell for cutting i do i'm wearing long time ago i paid 700 bucks
for this i swear if the profits aren't like a billion dollars 36 98 i'm really under cutting
the market with that one so yeah i get 20 bucks every time that sells so what 20 40
60 80 hundreds 120 140 160 180 200 to 20 and 240 so each batch of these i make 240 dollars profit
okay that's good that's what i want to see that's what i want to see mm-hmm that is what i'm talking
about mm-hmm you have a fantastic dnd session my love with your dice so many dice please buy a plushie
no not for you you don't have a daughter that would love a little cute little oink oink
hello uh hi mommy sorry for being like mind if i ask what happened it's getting scheduled to next
weekend uh i believe it's gonna be friday for you it's gonna be a saturday at four a.m for me
um yes it's been rescheduled to next week a few things i got messed around this week
no i see you coming in no i'm ready i'm ready at the door i kid you know i'm ready at the door
ah jump up jump up jump up there you go there you go you're welcome i did you a favor
what's this one two three four five six okay six people in again i was ready i was literally
like a dorm in there i was a bouncer get a stank out here so where's the back door i can't even get
in honestly i don't i think it must be in the fill game that they open this because this is even
accessible to me right now um right please don't get us so someone buy everything that would be great
just buy everything
you say sins the stinker there i got a hundred and seventy dollars surely so what happens if i try
and pay rent not enough money i'm very curious what happens in 30 minutes in in-game time
we're about to find uh get clean nerd no stinkers no stinking you should do the hakari dance what's that
mommy comes back from a long business trip and spends all day where we from catching up
on the team
how is that we doing
oh you're at the end of the day buddy i don't think anyone's gonna come and play with you
if they're gonna buy something but oh she's coming over
no dice not no dice
is anyone else coming in anyone want to play with my last customer
no i guess i'll play with roofling myself come here right are we about to be booted out because
i don't have rent paid uh
uh
infinite money glitch we don't even have to do anything
we don't have to pay for it
get rekt we don't have to pay for it
yeah
got debt just don't pay five head honestly right let's get these up
oh how you do that you're trolling me this box has no item in it
okay yeah you heard it here ladies and gentlemen if you have debt you don't need to pay for it
it's a dick i'm not in trouble the shop didn't shut down and before there's like a cut scene
that's about to happen and like someone walks in and like absolutely nabs us gets us rekt for it
oh see this is this is what i'm talking about keep bringing this on hold on did the game just wake up
did the game just wake up because i've been fighting for my life trying to get you guys to buy stuff
did the game just wake up good morning good morning sleepyhead
here's a sleepy weepy head it's a new video game people are actually buying stock hello
remember that time i played the turnip boy game and the walking sound sounded like farting and then
a refund thought it was farting for two hours straight i never said anything as well yeah i remember
literally okay i'll take it i'll take if you guys are buying i'm selling you know
why did that why is that so hard right what colors do we need
okay red has one left it's only six dollars profit like it's such a
ah stop being so blinding okay they need to definitely put a dark mode on that
that is so much money for that i don't know maybe we should try and get one of the youth
the green deck or maybe another table i don't know i don't know
look we're all figuring out the game for the first time together okay the game's not even released yet
so no you're not allowed to criticize my gameplay the game's not even released yet correct
you changed three dollars madame good luck on your pack openings
can you advertise i can do an event on my phone but that's it like it doesn't really seem to i mean
fuck it we can upcharge maybe i don't know if anyone's gonna show up but
her first plushy set oh my god don't hump it i know what i'm doing when i get around plushy though
on an unrelated note i know what i'm doing when i obtain a refling plushy it completely does not
correlate with my last sense i assure you there's no correlation whatsoever no correlation
oh my god that card was so skinny
37 40 there you go don't hump it i wonder how many cards are actually available it seems like
i'll go play somewhere else he says he's not gonna play the card tournament but he will buy the
product okay i've upcharged too much just make it 10 man should confirm whatever i don't know we'll
just we'll just make it right i'm happy with that if you're happy with that i don't think there's
really much more we could do other than like grains i'm taking my time for my grind
i didn't really see it doesn't i think if i was upcharging more sure but i maybe put more tables
than let's see what you are do you have a better pricing than freaking the red one because the red
one's rubbish the red one gives me four bucks can you at least give me something okay that one gives
me much more money oh my god people are actually buying items the game's speeding up all of a
sudden the game wants to be nice to me get out of here get out of here i already know what
it's i like how they waft it away as if i'm like not helping them de-stink
so how much is it for another table and cheers then 200 what that gets more destiny
can you sell individual cards i can but i can't be arsed setting them up
i didn't care for it i didn't care for the mechanic because it's like um literally pennies
like 35 cents like i'd rather
the link three two two thank you for the extended membership hi strongy hi link
hi missus it literally i do not care for 60 cents like i don't know i think you need that badly
well if you're gonna oh what are you gonna do with that vaporeon plushy sir should i be concerned
i don't know hold on no sorry the controls are a bit funny you wouldn't think they are what they are
and then put that back
someone technical crazy
like a vampire mommy the various mechanics in this game can be optimized by mean you're not aware of
is it selling cards that are open that are more expensive did you know that in terms of
this trying to have the same properties as the vaporeon
i might be a cuttlefish but i still go on the junk start a youtube channel and open your packs
loud yeah that'll do it that'll maximize actually why isn't oh wait actually that makes
i was about to say why isn't there a youtuber that opens card packs and has a store that they
endorse but people would just say like rigged like packets because you can like open them
there was something about like i could have sworn i heard about this it was like um if you weighed
the pokemon booster pack or whatever it was with a nano scale you would know if it was a reflective
shiny hollow elemental peon side because it was a it was like a little bit heavier than the other
packets and i remember learning about i'm like oh my god they people take take it very seriously
very seriously i would be glad to watch a hand cam opening pack streams oh boy do i have a treat
for you coming soon then or if the game let you collab with experts in the meadow there's some
wait these no meh these aren't real meh meh tiramon isn't real right is it real
oh are they not made up for the video game
in italy there is oh sorry give me that back it says hold to remove i'm holding
what i'm like to remove it oh that makes so much more sense well i know how to do refunds now
it only took me three hours to figure out how to do refund
aren't girls cute i love strony cardals my favorite tcg pack opening the main menu has
a roadmap saying create real tcg or something wait what
higher worker for automation rent and bill warehouse room more shop product more shelf
more tcg cloud save and achievement controllers oh game roadmap oh i was like am i supposed to do
this now right no sorry this is the development team's fucking note i was so sorry i was so
confused i was like what i was like uh why am i doing controller support and a cloud save what
does that mean i was like i'm not qualified for this i'm just i'm just the player what the heck
you want me to start coding in the middle of my card shop right customers trade cards difficulty
mode shop decoration playable tcg oh that's curious i'm not gonna be i don't want to be a
syskeptical that's not a word sceptical andy but i would be very interested if they did complete
that roadmap so this is early access i assume the way they're gonna play it is like oh we'll
a have updates as the game comes out but like i don't know i don't want to be a meanie boweenie
because i'm sure they put their love in it and their soul into it and everything syskeptical i'm
sorry some packs of special cards have specific weights yes where some buyers and scammers literally
came with an industrial weight scanner yeah like it was like a nano scale like down to like a
boh here why is hypnotizing customers to spend more money not on the roadmap exactly like i just i
don't understand right i assume i'm supposed to deal with the stinky customers are they like
make the other ones not feel good or something no i just got rid i just dealt with one of you
i'm jumping i'm i'm jumping you that's right inner psh oh my god did i ever tell you right this is
right before anyone starts laughing this is a mildly humorous story before anyone starts slapping
their knees saying this is the funniest thing they've ever heard it's amusing at most it's not that
exciting okay it's not that exciting stop letting out don't laugh so i didn't know that their automatic
air fresheners were a thing so when i visited my friend's house um we entered the room and
automatically went off because it it detected us and like i burst out laughing because i was like
what is that um and she was like oh it's just a smelly thing like smell it it makes the smell
and i was like it detects if you're stinky when you enter the room and sprays you and i was like
rolling on the floor i was like because um it detected that it was stinky when i entered the
room like i just found it the funniest thing ever and she was like surrounding it literally is just
automatic it senses you when you enter and i'm just i just found it the funniest thing because i
didn't even know it was like technology like that i'm like if it's stinky you're like a candle that's
where i come from you know these are there's where i'm from but uh yeah enter in the thing and it was
i was like what is that why is it on yourself geez
um you can sell the valuable cards to make a profit over selling boosters
i know but i want to complete my deck i don't know what it looks like i mean i'm not exactly
being open there's 106 pages but that's because there's hollows and like reverse shinies and stuff
card collection 59 out of 1272 uh dev team i think you cooked a little too hard maybe
consider the hollow and reverses just put a little checklist in front because that's a
bit you're cooking a bit too hard with that one that would be my honest feedback is don't count
the hollows the shinies the reverses as a new card thing because i know for a fact that that
does not seem right you're so damn cute do you know that well because i didn't know what's
like automatic fucking shit detectors were oh no that was another point it was like
oh there's one in the toilet as well and i'm like imagine not even like finishing your job
being a squirt see on the back no because it's like no this is fucking reek and
like this just this is just such a funny concept like i detect your stinky
i'm entertained easily okay i'm entertained easily it's the it's the simple things in life
it's the simple things no the beat no it's not even a bidet like imagine you stuck it to the
wall behind your toilet and you're just like minding your own business and then you get like
a wet spritz of perfume on your back and mid job but you're like excuse you and the machines
just staring back at you and not doing anything just blast the whole perfume and screams reloading
that's that oh my god you you have an indian and then you go to the toilet and all you hear is
the machine going because it's getting ready to like absolutely get ass blasted with perfume
uh oh stinky imagine a voice yelling foul beast i need to do a voice pack oh my gosh i'll do a
voice pack okay for your your automatic spritzer machine i'm just doing my job there are more than
18 000 different pokemon cards nintendo you need to calm down i know nintendo started with a deck
of cards nintendo you need to calm 18 000 18 000 how how she's she's not possible
well i'll pick a random tcg box to open we'll do a little hand cam stream
um actually i got a full refund from a lego set by the way and the seller oh my god they were so
nice they were like weird like i already said why is my track not working i'm looking straight at the
camera are you okay i'm looking i'm looking right at the camera i'm right here um the person that
sold me the hobbit lego set um so they got schemas so in turn i got schemas but i got a full refund
i also got vouchers and the person was like um i feel so bad i'm gonna i'll contact you if i'm able
to get another one of those in stock um type thing um and like offer you like a discount on
top like they're going above and beyond so little old me can have my little hobbit set so i swear to
god if i'm fucking communicating while reefing on the other side of the the lego thing that i'm
buying i swear to god i'm on to you because you're being far too nice um at least you got a refund
yet no they did not dispute it like i sent a photo and i was like so the booklet instruction isn't
even in it the lego pieces in the set aren't even from the hobbit set they're like neon red
um actually i could probably show you on the stream what i got because obviously he's not
asking for it back because the product ain't there um it's a good company literally um so um i got
really lucky because i was so when i arrived i just felt like something like i so what it was was
the box was shaking really weirdly and i like i had a pit in my stomach just i was like i've not got
what i've ordered i order um no don't say that um and i just knew and i opened it up and i just saw
it and i was like no this isn't right so i took photos i took videos and like sent it all off
and the guy was so apologetic um and like fill refund coupons if i wanted to buy any other sets
which i may i don't know i didn't see any other hobbit sets that i wanted or lord of the ring
just give me bag end oh my god just give me bag end mary and pippin you know one of them's in
farmer maggots field the other one's fishing sam's day in the garden like i do not know what lord
of the rings in lego i don't know who is on the development team who the fuck ordered the black
gate i get it the fight was cool who the fuck wants the black gate lego set because it's no me
you can charge a premium on hobbiton or on a detailed bag end set okay like
oh why have you not made the most wholesome gorgeous extract in the movies in the books why
not go for it i'll pay premium the black gate no the black gate wait what the black gate what
it's the same in my accent the black gate is the location and lord of the rings i'm not saying
what that read from type i'm not saying my type i'm saying gate
i'm saying gate oh my god you actually can't hear it gate uh gate yeah we see gate the cheese silent
is
yeah the tea's a wee bit silent scottish diva youtube please don't hurt me i'm scottish
what does scottish have against the teas it just depends like if the tea actually you know what
i'm gonna do a bit of a ramble i know i should be playing the game i'm gonna wrap it up is any
streaming later shebe's not well so i can't redirect into her so yes i'm gonna redirect you
into a room where inners is coming on later coming on my you're not allowed to say that well sometimes
i am mabzu is reviewing the worst iphone is that the next stream for vealer actually we're on
holodeck i need to message management to do the holodeck's tweet because we should have done that
yep stream it means 45 minutes okay right i don't feel bad about redirecting you if it's only
45 minutes away it's the worst iphone games games that's a short moment right there
you better clip it so i can ship it uh yeah i've got i think i've got two more shorts coming
and they don't stop coming and they don't stop coming but i'm gonna start doing uh i am so inspired
by eme and shebe i've seen some look i'm not leaking it okay but shebe's been working hard too
i'm gonna do some shorts about making asmr content or like how much it earn or how it works
blah blah blah so obviously asmr to me because i'm so used to it it doesn't like i don't think
anyone finds it interesting to learn about the behind the scenes but then i have to remember
that like because i've been doing it it seems mundane to me like when it comes to that stuff
mommy's shorts um ac got a subscriber jump i wonder why i wonder what stream ac did that
might have caused her to have an increase in subscribers truly truly a mystery i just i
can't even figure it out i wonder what what live stream did ac do hold on a minute hold on
that's my pc making that noise i'm taking a screenshot hold on i'm taking a screenshot
i just i can't for the life of me you know ac's been doing fantastic she's been keeping her head
down she's been working hard um i just i don't know why she had to jump in subscribers it was
really strange it was really strange i'm really strange i just i'm not sure oh i just made
myself tiny sorry hold on okay hold no no why the cards massive what and okay there we go
wait that's the thing uh go click the link in the description below to my genme ac snow paws and
go listen to it uh yeah it's a thing i think i'm gonna do it for 25k subscribers i'll do one too
and solidarity with my gen mates obviously solidarity um was it the members stream the
no the yeah i think for 25k we'll do the bingo bus is coming everybody jump on it from
ellie to san francisco we're going to a disco uh and then for 30k i'll do the 10 000 kisses
because that that one i may start early and the reason for that is the birds okay i was fighting
for my life in a membership ASMR stream the last one i did the birds start chirping they're chirping
now but i'm using the smb so you probably can 25k subs is today wait what are you serious
what what what what happened did did my last news to my video get
people says hey what did you do what did you do did you do something are you
what did you do what did you do reflames
reflames
what did you do are you doing something
i'm looking at my analytics
uh maybe um there's not really the last jump in subscribers i had was from the thigh ASMR
the in real life thigh ASMR i had to jump yesterday but i think that's because the ASMR video went
hold on we're analyzing my content live we're analyzing it live did the new video
the new video i gained 85 subscribers from it i guess i got 100 did i get 100 every ASMR
video upload now hold on a minute the blowing ASMR got me 83 subscribers the ASMR collab with
side got me 50 the pregnant with you got me 200 damn the pregnancy bros really enjoyed that one
oh i guess it's okay now the real the real thigh company is some more one it did get trending
that gained me 2,600 subscribers oh no don't make me chase trends
the dempo got me 100
um i got 100 from the wolf momica lab Scottish last cleans your ears got me 400
thank you trending are people just not expecting me to do serious ASMR clapping with no hands ASMR
has no stats because it died but i'm gonna try and upload it again um
oh god mimosa's dead riff and piss mimosa collab got me 40 what the fuck
yes steady solid growth honestly you collab with you know and through you that might have
also done a wee bit as well it wasn't um how strange thank you everyone who does subscribe
what on earth 25k from shit posting on overwatch for ASMR
you should do an outrageous behavior vtuber or were you rank outrageous vtuber
i would need clips of them i would have to farm clips of vtubers and be like rating vtubers
based on the clips of them that i made maybe the baby pink as well oh that's right and peaches
collab is coming out too yeah no yeah i can see it wow holy moly holy moly thank you everyone that
does subscribe uh uh i just i don't have words to say like just god damn i did not expect the
thank you it's very i promise i'm at the the next um the ear brushing the the 6000 milestone is
getting uploaded tomorrow you're welcome uh i'm going to yeah i love how we can see aces
tango what are you talking about i don't see no tank wait how is go how is that in front of i can't
hate it a little bit it's on the shelf you can purchase it okay it's on the shelf or you can
purchase a vtuber hand asset in the background your choice dealer's choice what would you like to buy
hi what would you like to buy in my tcg car shop 75k more to play button
is ac okay yeah she's for sale on the the shelf
are you squiddling me right now brian all i did was sub after the pregnant with us again
and thank you again because for having listened to a bunch of ubs mr it was clearly one of the
best i've listened to in a long time thank you what a compliment thank you aria love indy i've
absolutely butchered your name there's no way aria love indy thank you what a compliment
no that was the first time i ever did uh i didn't expect to enjoy making it so much so i
i obviously when you look at the surface of the role play it is very me me but i think when you
go inside you're like damn she tried and i did try i wanted it to be all cute
buying a hand why not buy the arms starting how you doing it gets i'm wrapping up though i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry emi's coming on in a moment we're redirecting into emi though
my i says no for you can we buy more me uh yeah
how much i would like to charge one delicious chocolate chip cookie i'm gonna say something
controversial i haven't had one nice cookie in australia i miss i miss the good scottish
chocolate chip cookie i'm sorry i want i just want one chocolate chip cookie that's nice i have
not had a good one in australia i don't know what it is i just struggle to eat them here
i can't idea all right brothers we need to keep chilling and promoting valour and support
we love you and hope it shows oh thank you um no the girls have been doing fantastic as i said
the baby pink collab went up if you didn't see it i'm gonna make a community post about it because
i forgot to do that um and then i'm going to uh there's gonna be a peaches asmr collab next
and then the next kind of large scale type thing that might be happening at the allure is for the
talents that have more than 10 asmr roleplays um let's just say you might be watching you know
your local asmr's in a roleplay and then one of my girls might pop up and whisper and say that they
also do asmr i'm gonna do a little ad campaign inside asmr videos for asmrists of my girls
it's gonna be ridiculous we're gonna try like because it might just be like absolutely hated
um but it's gonna be like a really quick clip insert um and obviously i'm gonna pay asmr
is for it because uh vas asmrists love them lovely people um sponsorship opportunities
come so few and far between and uh they try so hard the community try so hard they're fantastic um
and it's another way of being like hey do you want to make money whilst helping my girls guess what
um so yes the the only catch what not the shilling i know the only catch was the girls
that get in that ad campaign they do need to have like 10 asmr roleplays up because there's
no point in saying hey i do asmr and it's like like all livestreams or whatever um as always no
i'm not advertising myself in it because no uh not for me but i'll advertise them i'll put money
behind them uh emmy has 43k subs yes i told her i'ma put this on record right now little sister
that's right you listen to yum listen to your mommy um oh she sent me that and i was sending
on to the editors and i told her that one's gonna blow up and she said actually i'm gonna expose
you right now emmy i'm oh wait do i have access to it i might expose what emmy right here we go
i said in in quotation marks holy shit that anime voice one is gonna pop the fuck off and then emmy
responded with the x to doubt meme from le noir i told you emmy i told you okay i know the algorithm
i know what people like i told you yes leaking i told her she didn't believe me she didn't believe
me i told her and mummy was right you're done shebe also has one i told her i know which one's
gonna be pop the most popular um of everything she showed me i know which one's gonna be the most
popular i'm putting money on it too and if it and if it does get the most popular i told you shebe
i didn't get why none of you sir no try listen to your mummy after plain overwatch call me Anna
because listen to your mummy do you really believe oh i believe in all my daughters i believe in the
mom no matter how many subs she has she's mine first i will fight excuse you that's my little sister
that i burst from my loins i have access first uh word word to your mother okay Anna listen to
your mummy i like that voice line i like Anna's voice as well because she's got like a vocal
fry but it's not like it's like you know a big deal burst burst from your loins from our DNA
manju uh yeah who who has more of a birthright to me the brother was it how did it like daughter
sister um big sister little sister my mummy milk our mummy who birthed her for i had an umbilical
cord around her for 12 months okay i have this birthright to forget the binding of Isaac
birthright pick between three items i have the birthright to my daughter as well it's getting
saying it in these sentence structures makes it awfully strange um call me chimera because i'm
every spot on the family to you what's a chimera we're in the digital age you're allowed to look
up things you don't know chimera in greek mythology is a fire breathing female monster resembling
a lying in the four part a goat in the middle and a dragon behind she devastated Saria and Lycia
until she was slain by beller othon
oh chimera chimera
around her oh do you not know most umbilical cords actually strangle uh
fetuses in the womb it's very common um for babies to come out with an umbilical cord around
their neck and it's a bit of a panic but it's very stressful um however you're still as a baby
getting an oxygen supply through the umbilical cord um i got strangled on the way out yeah it's
very common i was strangled by the cord at birth almost perished it is it can be you still do get
a bit of oxygen supply through the umbilical cord even after but um yeah holy shit i missed the whole
stream i'm sorry i don't know if it helps at a stream at the same time every single day i'm so
sorry if it's bad it was a shorter stream today because i'm gonna go for a baby a baby no i'm not
going for a baby i'm going for a bath because we're talking about i'm not don't impregnate me not yet
not yet i'm going for a bath i'm going for a bath do not impregnate me yet okay a bath i'm putting
bubbles in the bath i'm putting bubbles at gensu here we come no no no no no no wait wait wait wait
no no yeah yeah yeah soon october soon um too late i was thinking about my first bansley stream
and i thought it would be really nice and symbolic if we did i'd try and did my first
life and then the input me
um ever seen 300 guys go for it at the same time you have never i didn't mean to say i did
the bansley but yeah um should i put the flowers brian brian you see it should i put the flowers
and candles away then mama are you trying to be nice to me in the bathtub
are you oh wait no you can put it on the bed as well oh you're real sorry sorry judging karma
wait i was thinking sorry i was thinking about the bath i mean you can put flowers and candles
in the bath it's like little petals in the water uh sleepy phoenix and structures unclear gen two
conceived real real gen two when are we doing gen five roll out no as much as i like to have a
giggle i cannot go above three okay i do not have the team above three unless i can somehow
find someone i cannot go past gen and to be honest i feel like after gen three i'm spent
you know mommy mommy's been mommy's had enough of giving birth after gen three it's i i i will
say this i will i would like to declare i would like to declare publicly um i have been very lucky
with my gen one choices um if you want to get a wee bit serious for a moment um obviously now
with the success of gen one those who apply to gen two or three if we are that lucky to
extend our efforts you know i was kind of talking to one of the team members and they said something
that came to rung a bell and it was along the lines of why didn't you apply to gen one did you not
believe in us and now you only believe in us because you saw the success now don't get me wrong i
understand not wanting to be a founding member but mersey azura emi ac sheebie all saw the potential
in me and what i planned and what i was going to do they saw that and they went for the founding
member and for that i will never be able to show them my true gratitude for this but that raises
the question that for gen two applicants it's like well how did you hear about veal or did you hear
about us when we first came out and said nah i'm not gonna apply i don't trust it you know it there's
a lot of there's a lot of like there's uh what how would i describe it think of a laser beam in a
room full of mirrors is how i would describe it because it's like well if you didn't do that why
do you want to know why why did this happen why did that happen hold on i you know i'm okay to say
that i'm very nervous about gen two applicants but i'm very happy to say that um the girls are
gonna help me i have um extra team members as well that are coming through instructions unclear
shag the bathtub no don't shag the plughole no mo mo mo take it out it's gonna get stuck
thank you for the super chat a wider application pool let's you select the best yes
what i'm trying to get a right now obviously don't get me wrong of course where there's success
people are gonna want success as well please don't think like i'm being weird about it no
fucking apply if you want success like fuck sake i'll you know i'll help you out what my what my
thing is is why didn't you apply for gen one and now you want to apply to gen two because you saw
the money you saw the success and it's like did you not believe in us it you know it has a bit of
like je ne sais quoi about it um and there's so many attributes as well because obviously of
course people are gonna see this he says and be like i went in on that money i want whole bags
affectionately that yes you want money at the end of the day we're not a greedy company but you
know you also want to work you also want to foster the community hopefully you know if i could
fucking grab another batch of gen one fantastic no questions asked you know instructions unclear
tentacle is now stuck in the toaster why are you humping a toaster doesn't that zap you wouldn't that hurt
i mean you know you know you guys are wet right to the touch
you guys are slimy right you know that thank you the bit of lord but you are slimy you can't
really touch electronics as well um it's a different spirit to the ones that take the
risks and the ones that are a bit more optimistic and seeing the results yes that's also very fair
to say obviously i'm not gonna be like oh my god i'm not accepting anyone because you didn't play
for gen one what i'm trying to say is to give it another perspective is the founding members and
obviously everyone else that respectfully applied um saw something in the company right before it even
launched right but gen two you can argue that they saw the success and want that type thing
anyway look we're gonna do our aspects i'm gonna fucking pull all the strings as always reeflands
you guys are gonna help me out too uh oh failure why are you so based in awesome that you let people
publicly declare they applied for your agency
yeah oh you should tweet that you applied do it do it tweet that you applied for no particular reason
at all we're getting visec to meet no oh after gen three maybe then you can do all the cream pies
you're like maybe no hold on a minute you go hold on a minute you have a point there you have a
point there uh you would have to remember who applied for gen one uh let's just say my autism is
very good um i was the one who went through the introduction videos um and like to this day i still
remember a lot of details about them and it's been months you know um we can do that now too
strong using the reeflands as our own cia no what are you talking about what i would never do
something like that i wouldn't i wouldn't send you to go do op specs and warn me about
then you say why are we talking about
activate or sleep in agent program five seventeen twenty two twenty six zero
risoka that was a black ops one reference if you remember any of that hey mom what models
are you putting sins mom on so we can get that leaked already real and true
so sins model is just an even milfier version of sin you heard it here folks so i can't have
sins ip back and have the milf version shawty would never use this as a screening force to weed
out the bag eggs how dare you attack her under flawless character but trust you guys so when
is the first black budget operation wait what does that mean black budget operation when i pay you
guys for it wrong activation but no don't be sick don't be pukey are we continuing the game oh no
sorry that's me done sorry i'm yapping for emmy i'm so sorry i i think emmy's about to go up in
like 20 minutes if i'm not mistaken if i'm not mistaken emmy's about to go live in 20 minutes
yes she is okay i will play 20 minutes more the game okay let's see if we can unlock all the plushies
sorry sorry i'm yapping oh my god ac still on the shelf hold on ac still on the shelf right clear
clear assets clear clear right there we go and then pop me down here sorry sorry i didn't realize
i was yapping that much sorry i just look i love a good i love a good yeah okay you can pay rent
no we're going for plushies ac's on the shelf forget elf on the shelf ac's on the shelf
i mean she is tiny enough to get up you can jump
hello everybody welcome back to my youtube gameplay of uh what is this game called uh tc
chair cart shop jambalaya prologue oh there's two people walking in beside each other honestly me
and the reeflands are so in sync this week no you ruined my joke i was gonna say we're so in sync
she found out after three hours you can jump honestly in 20 minutes in september another month
on i no longer say i see what i see his talk shelf not that you do hey everybody how's it going
um my name is stra- any cuddles and don't forget to
oh hello sorry i've forgotten completely my conduct in this game it's been
remember mellows are a thing brothers you mean marshmallows you're allowed to say marshmallow
that's allowed you're allowed to do what you want and marshmallow okay right we're gonna unlock the
next plushies i want all the plushies look these gender norms have hands girl bitches love plushies
i'm bitches okay i can't i'm oh can you imagine the violour plushie match everything's getting
humped well no actually no only the reeflands the other uh girls's plushies are getting ASMR'd on
by me right figures i need $700 reduced got it oh no you're losing oh no
i think it would be cute if they had like a self-serve area like a uh a ramen thing a ramen
nails i got nothing to send yet waiting for that reefland plushie pick where it's officially
no i'm gonna cream my crackers honestly i'm gonna i'm gonna be squealing i'm gonna be a
like a pig in shit i'm gonna be that bloody ape when i see a reefland plushie i'm gonna do
all i'm gonna so many hand cam streams on you we're just so many ASMR's on you
gonna fucking milk your little two tentacles at the front
that's you can't i'm sorry i don't know why i'm hyped all of a sudden i need to
cam right i'm at seven let's turn it back down to four okay i'm supposed to be in agony right
now i'm i'm enjoying my painkillers look they feel good i've been hydrating for once
you know the shop is doing well two dollars fitting you can't wait
the plushie would be constantly wet i'm gonna have to put it through the washing machine
a couple of times i'll need to hang you to dry on the washing line oh my god no my neighbors
are gonna be like why does she always have that plushie out there drying the neighbor
crank that shit up soldier boy okay seven who level eight
level eight
you know what i think oh sorry for waiting madame i do apologize i was too busy being shocked
right i think we're just gonna put more tables in i kid you know i think more tables leads to
more people showing up fuck it another one fuck it another another give me another i don't know
are you squid me brian heard of elf on a shelf now get ready for a seara on a mula shebe on a
beanie mercy on a turkey icy on a micy strone on a bonnie in me on bini that was really creative
how did you do that wait hold on i'm gonna do it you need to put it against the wall so people can
still enter the shop how did you do that thank you tiny spainy how did you do that
uh strone on a bonnie wait no this is a rain strone on a bonnie oh bonnie strone on a bonnie
oh sorry i'm just thinking about your turn of class
eeps eeps i didn't mean it like that you can't prove it was me okay can i not fit that there
bro i'm gonna be playing you i can't i don't have the space
sorry no bonnie sorry
right can i fit there is no bro this shop is getting a bit too busy who said
this shop is getting a wee bit too busy for canal this is the best i can do with what i got
this is a bit this is all i got this is all i can do it's too smelly we'll go deal with that
oh that's so that's what the complaints are no geez do not charge that poor man four thousand
nine thousand right all yours okay right enough of the stinking you're upsetting no pop it down
okay as i said we'll redirect into emmerz in 20 minutes so tell me when she goes up and then
we'll wrap it up uh i don't know if we'll play again when the full game comes out if the full
game looks like it will it has like major advancements then yeah we'll probably play it again
she's too h-word look someone mentioned impregnate wasn't it me i said i was going for a bath okay
i don't know what's going on in your i don't know what's going on in your head hydration check
maybe you need more space a little bit a little bit can i even upgrade
oh i can not oh i can dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb i need some four hundred dollars and then i
unlock the next this cube is why i assume i unlock next this card is way too overpriced
then diney buy it then it's called premium mate all right seven one two three four five
oh no give me that back
wait what i drank too fast no don't be like my poor baby you must have really sore throats all the time
well i didn't mean it like that now hold on a minute did not mean it like that i just meant
because you puke a lot okay it's just because you puke a lot uh right okay now we can expand
so press tab big rental ooh uh i thought it was gonna be bigger are you serious are you serious
right okay how are we doing this put you over there can i like can i rotate you
okay oh oh right okay and then this doesn't have to be so claustrophobic now
oh god why does that look so odd
oh my god i'm a size queen when it comes to a shop in a shop only i'm trying to line it up
perfectly i can't my mouse
how did you even fit around there you're so skinny need to fatten you up
hmm i'm wondering would having more shelves affect i don't have enough money for that
would it affect the the mpc the more it's falling if i had even more shelves
oh i have a i forgot i had a table out there my bed can i move this can i do that i can okay so one
more table right okay yes so people you can have a card tcg date whilst everyone watches you
and buys deodorant right next to you okay this clearly is a problem if you have too many tables
because they too beefland my darling manage event sure confirm event sure bring everyone in
pop them like one soldier boy crank that shit i'm a man are you sp e or sph what's sp e
encouragement the chair is out in the sun yeah you're gonna get vitamin d if you sit here
oh that's the sun even in just the light encouragement
i can do both whatever makes you happy whatever your fantasy is let me fulfill it i want to i need
to redo the you look lonely scene instead of the you look lonely it's like you look hmm h word
i can fix that and then you tell me what your interests are and then i fulfill your intro
get in the d vitamin d yes vitamin d as in vitamin dick
you started it wasn't me i finished it you were thinking it i just finished the sentence jeez
try to say i'm not funny oh no i think that would be your version
you look are wordable let me fix that
oh wait no let me fix that would change let me help with that oh no
you're doing good yeah we playing the crap out of this game
no run this is stinking me flings you forgive me when you show or with soap afterwards you
move all the stink okay you need to put the order and on to stop the stink coming back for 24 hours
and then you wash again some people say that taking a shower at night is icky and that it's nicer to
see at your welcome right i'm gonna buy shelves i think with my next income i think if there's
more shelves maybe more customers is how the ai is working i'm getting rather i'm trying to figure
out how the ai will increase my customers yeah you look are wordable let me prove it
but oh can we get away with it though
give me your income i thought it was funny but then again i've done something
for you
okay they finished playing and then if i can make 250 books
or here's your change madam okay and then we're gonna buy another shelf and i'm gonna pretend
that's somehow gonna be wait it's 150 for a single or 800 for a doubler just freaking put
two behind each other can't be that serious can it be right so this corner doesn't like
anything to be put in it okay it must be because it's just gonna go
if i'm quirky enough and move it over as much as it all is
uh-huh no uh-huh easy wait what it does no no go back okay there definitely is like a
we need space to be able to move in the shop coming in okay so we have a second shelf
i guess i'll just fill it right we need to maybe focus on restocking the shelves so
there's booster packs are plenty but i need those boxes can that have enough for the box
you open the box i came no stinkling you keep forgetting you need to wash your belly button
too oh hold on you need to wash your belly button i'm behind your ears you keep forgetting
yeah just just use soap and a washcloth and go and then your skin will be
ink milking session you look you look brainwrotted let's make it worse as the hours pass i will let
you know i am so skeepity on your lips she be dee be dee she be dee dead by daily stop oh no no
i don't want to do that because my brain's gonna start saying that sorry
forgive me the brainwrots too strong right let's at least put something on the shelves here
there right because yeah right all right wrap up your games i want to go home i need to sleep
and eat to you know can't be standing around there's a shame i don't have a chair you know
i need a little chair mommy is reefing so much they go cross-eyed i give you a hey girl instead
of me a hey girl you get it instead i can't dig anymore i wonder where debt bill is
seven hundred dollars
we don't talk about the seven hundred dollars right come on wrap it up we'll wrap it up wrap up them
games i hate you maybe because i've levelled up i get more things from unopening packs i don't know
right i'll let them wrap it up i'm gonna open packs in the corner
hold to open
uh-huh okay okay we got a little shiny on that little shine on the border
yeah like uh-huh uh-huh that nine dollars for that one honestly maybe that is the matter
just sell the most expensive cards you have but i want to collect
oh that was five bucks but it was a duplicate that was new that was new
maybe if i just sell duplicate expensive ones then that makes sense
uh all doops where boom
opponent discard discard one card at random damn
have you read name of the wind great book and there's a character in it that you'd like
does it have a knot sorry i don't know what's going on i've been quite rather inappropriate
to do i didn't declare i don't apologize i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i love how you pronounce
oh god how do you say it
outrageous i don't oh it's uh shiny and cool and glitter and feel pretty shapes and colors
you you gx game on get your game on game on get to get your cards right
i hate you i hate you i hate you i hate you you're an ethos get your game on get laid all the
clitters of gold oh sorry you were waiting on me i'm just opening packs and singing to myself
to apologize thank you my good sir any change no change thank you very much
you literally just look right whoops sorry right i guess what we'll go for then
dice have i even got enough for more days they're so it's being said the
right what claw do not have i don't have blue i don't have red
there's another dice there that we don't have yeah i'm sure 200 for pox
unique candy but sure i'll put it in my basket that's going straight in my bar right uh next day
so we had 31 customers the day what does that mean what's that mean
i think we all just learned to pronounce it differently i always read it as a hegeo
whenever i read my way my uh mangas my uh dojins or dojins i mean two minutes okay
i'll i can't level up fast enough there must be some secret i feel like i'll leveled up so quick
and i'm not anymore i must be maybe card sales is what it is
japanese is poetic so it's
a hego i still a wego i'm doing a hego after the refunds been with me i don't you always pronounce
some words you always pronounce some words like you pronounce the t in scottish well you weren't
right but you were very cute oh that's the main thing oh ti crimson i think i forgot to say
mangas how do we call it nowadays i say manga but i guess it's like more one-shot dojins
well she's out control wait in ospanish no signor no
i'm sorry i don't know espanol
no this is your landlord pay your rent i took this reefling as captain no okay maybe i will
pay my rent for once oh my god sorry i forgot i didn't open the shelf either she knows does
what does that mean i don't know netherlands snap head i don't know no i do know xnap head
oh
my mouse just went flying to space did you hear that
real origin one indulge
and i used to be able to count in dutch as well
i ain't why oh no i sound german
i ain't why did i be or no that's german i used to be able to count in netherlands
because it's like 20 can ain 20 can play 20 can do the year 20 can win me right now
the chicas call me happy chulo the chicas call me pappy chul what is that chul
i like how it's my responsibility to deal with the stinky customers as well emers is live okay
we're gonna wrap up this day and then we're gonna redirect into my little shit
i keep hitting enter to give the money thing back right wrap up everyone go home get out
emmy's live everyone get out of here get out get out of the shop emmy's live get the fuck out of
here
there we go how you get i got emmy's live go home and watch emmy smack
behind the head didn't you know the news emmy's live what you spanker on the ass you never saw that
didn't emmy beezoo your little sister yeah did you forget wallops or tits so they start
i don't know it sounds possessed me today clearly okay
right let me make sure i'm redirecting into her before i do it and then nothing happens
because i got six right right let me redirect let me redirect um okay virus speed run any percent
i swear god if she does get a virus emmy my beloved my beloved please be careful don't
actually get but i think i for real think i just got a virus um i've missed you already i'm coming
back tomorrow i don't know what we're doing tomorrow though cult of the lamb is too long for the current
condition i'm in unfortunately but maybe maybe baby maybe baby i don't know that's relatively
short but exciting and before it's just another stream snipe because i just want to i want to
play spider game with you actually right okay i'm gonna go and redirect into emmy emmy beezoo
you'll never guess what emmy's surname means in french en franais bisous oh bisous en anglais kiss
emmy's name means kiss so you better kiss your sister um
um
relatively short and exciting isn't that just for only stop it actually you're getting an
applause for that one that was a good one you're getting a applause for that one that was a good
one um right i'll see you cutie but tootie but tootie but cutie's tomorrow uh i don't know what
the agenda is yet you'll find out when i find out because i need to figure it out and then get
okay so i see you alligators tomorrow please enjoy emmy as always sorry it was shorter but
if you want to hear me scream feel free to put the vod on of overwatch too i'm gonna go for a bath
um and brain rot and tiki talk so maybe i'll have something funny to tell you tomorrow maybe not
you never know i should just a short four-hour stream that was four hours what the fuck i was
only to stream for two hours i didn't know that was four hours time flies when you get to be with
the person you love love you thank you for making me really happy sorry to get sappy for a moment but
i just get really happy doing stuff for you okay now i wouldn't i won't be too sappy okay i won't
be too sappy i'll keep it i'll keep it inside i'll keep it inside because you've given me lots of
ASMR ideas to think about as well now that i've got loads of things in my notes to do
and i'll confirm if i ordered the mic okay eh i need the mic for a very special
thanks for this dream i love you no i love all over loves all over your face
how many kisses run day 12 or i suppose we're only shop level six i probably could have farmed
a bit more but i didn't realize okay i didn't realize okay i gave six kisses for our levels
all right six six did i miss anything important in the stream no i'm just being cheating down
okay go and say hi to emi from me and i'll post the link just in case it dies
but she's lies right that's the link in case the redirect doesn't work okay
i love you refland i see you tomorrow bye bye i'll i'll i'll do something i don't know what yet
but i'll do something i'm not gonna rot in the bath okay
come on bye bye
no stop stall and reduce it very all of you bye go enjoy emi